Morgen, Lino. Guten Morgen Tim.
Aber wenn jetzt die Kirche schon WLAN anbietet, könnten wir das ja eigentlich auch machen, so Hotspot, Netzpolitik oder sowas.
Ja, aber das äh ich meine kannst du denn IPV sechs Tim?
Lokbuchennetzpolitik Nummer einhundertzweiundachtzig, euer Legacy Podcast zur Bekämpfung der Zukunft.
Nein, Quatsch, natürlich, wir sprechen hier alles. V sechs, vor sieben, vor acht. Also, welchen Motor man auch immer einbauen will, kein Problem. Das meintest du doch, oder?
HTTP zwei Punkt null.
Wir arbeiten dran. Die Meterebene äh erhält SU Speak hat sie gerade einen äh eine signifikante Infrastrukturerneuerung bekommen.
Und das heißt, jetzt funktioniert alles nicht mehr, oder was? Vorhand nehmen. Wie hast du vorher kein.
Läuft jetzt auch vor acht Motor. Nein, der Download, der Downloadserver war dem Ansturm ähm in der alten Konfiration nicht gewachsen. Und jetzt äh habe ich mir da mal was geklickt.
Robin, schön.
Genau, Experten, führende Experten, führende Netzexperten, haben sich da mal äh betätigt und ich bin gespannt, wie die Auslieferung so läuft. Wer das war.
Wer war das? Wer das war? Ja.
Der Reimers.
Kenne ich nicht. Kenne ich den? Nee, ne.
Macht Studiolink.
Ach der, ja, ah, okay, alles klar, ich.
Der hat mal die Turbotaste gedrückt und jetzt gucken wir mal.
Jetzt geht's rund. Der weiß ja, wie das ist mit dem mit dem verteilten Echtzeitaudio.
Der weiß Bescheid. Ja, aber.
Sag mal kurz Fitterhändel, falls die Leute Probleme haben, dass sie sich.
Het Linuzifa
So, genug gespaßt, äh jetzt wird's ernst. Äh wir hatten eine Woche Pause. Leider ging nicht anders. Ähm.
Also hätte schon anders gehen könnten, aber du wolltest ja nicht. Du warst ja weg. Das habe ich aber gesagt.
Na du warst ja weg. Muss uns doch deinen Podcast, weißt du auch? Ich bin doch hier nur dein Steigbügelhalter. Sonne mit Sonne mich in deinem Schatten.
Hätte er mich in deinem Schatten. Wir sind persönlich enttäuscht.
Ernsthaft? Wovon.
Also Gesamtsituation sitzt da irgendwie äh in fernen Ländern und will Podcast hören, kommt kein Podcast.
Er muss halt äh auf zweiter und Drittpodcast ausweichen. Es äh so lernt man auch mal neue Freunde kennen.
Gut, aber ich habe mit einem gewissen Anspruch habe ich ja auch.
Ach so, du meinst hörst nur deine eigenen Podcasts.
Hört man seine eigene.
Sich selber Inspiration genug.
Ach na ja gut, also ihr seht auch die Pause hat nicht dazu geführt, dass wir unseren Humor vollständig verloren haben.
Ja, es wird halt nur immer schlechter. Nutz dich halt ab.
Die und die Attraktivität dieser Sendung ist auch noch nicht komplett äh im Keller, denn es gelingt uns zumindest noch, Gäste einzuladen und wir begrüßen allen solchen, nämlich Volker, Volker Trip, hallo. Willkommen bei Logbuch Netzpolitik. Du warst ja noch nicht hier.
Aber wir dachten, äh das wäre doch mal eine ganz gute Idee, dich einzuladen. Du bist äh auch von der digitalen Gesellschaft und zusammen mit dem Alexander Sander, der schon mal hier war, einmal zweimal. Einmal glaube ich, ne? Ähm,
Ihr teilt euch quasi so ein bisschen die die Leitung oder wie muss man das verstehen oder.
Sind die beiden Festangestellten Mitarbeiter, die der Verein hat. Ansonsten wir haben ja ordentliche Mitglieder und Fördermitglieder und daneben betreiben wir eben noch ein Büro. Und ähm in dem Büro sitzen Alexander und ich, er als Hauptgeschäftsführer, ich als politischer Geschäftsführer.
Was was heißt politischer Geschäfte, also du kümmerst dich nicht um die Abrechnung oder.
Genau. Den ganzen nervt tötenden Verwaltungskram, den musste ich jetzt weniger machen, sondern eben eher das inhaltliche Positionspapiere, Analysen, Strategien und so.
Lobbyist. Lobby ist für.
Das ist genau das habe ich mal gelernt, ja.
Ja mit welcher Ausrichtung so.
Äh mein Schwerpunkt war immer öffentliches Recht. Ich habe auch ein Zeitlang als Anwalt gearbeitet in dem Bereich öffentliches Recht, also Verwaltungsrecht, Verfassungsrecht, Europarecht.
Also all die Dinge, die man auch durchaus ganz gut brauchen kann, wenn man sich mit Gesetzgebungsverfahren und solchen Dingen befasst.
Ja und das tut ihr ja auch. Hm. Unter anderem.
Genau. Unter anderem mit einem, glaube ich, über das wir heute auch sprechen wollen, oder?
Genau, fangen wir da schon mit an oder wollen wir noch ein paar.
Ich sehe noch äh du hast ein juristisches Repitorium in Berlin betrieben. Was, was ist ein Repetitorium.
Ja ne, äh wie der Name schon sagt, äh ähm ganz genau, also es ist eine Examensvorbereitung für Studenten und für Referendare und,
dessen privatwirtschaftliches Unternehmen, das ist so bei den Juristen relativ üblich, bei den BWLern und gibt's das auch noch, bei den Medizinern so ein bisschen, aber in anderen Studienfächern eher nicht so. Hintergrund ist
eigentlich nur, dass ähm sagen wir mal die universitäre Ausbildung ähm im juristischen Bereich und dann die Anforderungen im Examen eigentlich ziemlich weit divergieren. Ne, das liegt eben auch daran, dass die Prüfung von der Behörde abgenommen wird von dem
Justizprüfungsamt und die Ausbildung eben an der Uni läuft und so und ähm da setzen die Professoren häufig so die Schwerpunkte, die sie selber für richtig halten.
Und ähm genau. Dann ergibt sich eine Lücke und diese Lücke, die füllen seit weiß nicht Jahrzehnten eben Refilitorien, die dann so Kurse anbieten, um die Leute punktgenaus Examen vorzubereiten.
Nachhilfe sozusagen.
Ja, aber es machen halt so, ich glaube über neunzig Prozent der Jurastudenten und bei den Referendaren sind's auch noch so roundabout, fünfundachtzig Prozent.
Das haben wir in etablierte Branche.
Könnte man sagen ja.
Und du hast auch einen Podcast, nämlich äh einmal die Woche äh von Flux FM. Sechzehn, jeden Mittwoch um sechzehn Uhr zehn.
Ja, das bin weniger ich, sondern das äh ist eben der digitale Gesellschaft e. V. Alex und ich bespielen so diesen Spot. Abwechselnd und wir erzählen einmal die Woche, mal mittwochs um sechzehn Uhr zehn auf Lux ähm,
Ja, was über das aktuelle, netzpolitische Thema der Woche. Wir suchen uns immer ein Thema raus und versuchen das dann so ein bisschen zu beleuchten. Politischen Implikationen zu beleuchten, so.
Ja, wir stellen es äh nachträglich immer auf äh YouTube ähm und auf Soundcloud und da kann man das dann nachhören.
Mhm. Aber es Podcast gibt's das nicht oder was.
Nicht als er, nicht als klassischen Podcast, also auf auf Soundcloud ist es dann eben einfach nur.
Soundchock kann man doch glaube ich ein ein Feed rausrindern oder?
Da reden wir dann nochmal drüber.
Naja, da hast du jetzt den falschen erwischt natürlich Volker.
Ja, dann kommen wir doch gleich mal zu dem ersten Thema, was dich unmittelbar auch betrifft, weil ja auch gerade die digitale Gesellschaft sich dort äh extrem betätigt hat, nämlich
die störerhaftung, die ja nun bei uns auch schon länger im Gespräch ist und wo es ja nun seit Jahren immer hin und her geht,
und wo nun äh Anfang letzter Woche die große Nachricht durchbrach, dass ähm Politiker ähm offenbar,
zu Sinnen kommen. So wird es zumindest kolportiert. Ähm,
Ja, was ist passiert? Die Störerhaftung, die ja lange unter Beschuss ist und wo äh es ja auch eine Vielzahl von konkreten Vorschlägen gegeben hat, wie man denn das vielleicht.
Eigentlich mal regeln sollte äh last but not least euer Vorschlag von vor drei Jahren vier.
Na, vier Jahre, zweitausendzwölf, ja.
Ist ja nicht länger her.
Nee, zweitausendzwölf.
Achtundzwanzig C drei war das. Wenn der ja okay.
Ja, der, der insofern ja auch bemerkenswert war, als es sich dabei nicht nur so um eine pampfletisierte politische Forderung äh handelte, sondern ihr euch quasi die Mühe gemacht habt,
konkreten Gesetzesentwurf zu schreiben, die man so mit Copy und Pace hätte übernehmen können und dann werden wir genau da, wo wir jetzt vielleicht unter Umständen auch hinkommen, das müssen wir jetzt gleich nochmal äh beleuchten, was ja nun eigentlich passiert ist. Ja, ja, was ist denn eigentlich passiert.
Ähm unlängst? Ja, also nach allem, was man hört, haben sich Union und SPD äh darauf geeinigt, dass sie die störerhaftung abschaffen wollen,
Das ist eigentlich alles, was man bisher weiß. Ähm und was man auch noch weiß, ist das für den zweiten Julei
Entschuldigung, you know, die Sache auf der Tagesordnung im Bundestag steht, also da soll tatsächlich das Gesetz
durchs Plenum, den Text hat allerdings bisher niemand außerhalb von Union und SPD gesehen, das heißt, äh, was ganz genau da auf uns zukommt, weiß man eigentlich noch gar nicht.
Aber weiß man denn, dass sie so einen Text gibt.
Ja, dem wird's wohl geben, ne? Über irgendwas muss man ja abstimmen. Das wird sonst ein wenig schwierig. Ähm,
Aber wie gesagt, was genau drinsteht, weiß man nicht. Das Einzige, was man weiß, ähm ist, dass es eben Äußerungen gab, ähm so von,
Personen aus der Union, aus der SPD
Und da kann man versuchen so ein bisschen Rückschlüsse rauszuziehen. Und äh was betont wurde von äh mehreren Abgeordneten war eben
das Abmahnungen weiter na oder nicht Abmahnungen weiter möglich werden, sondern dass es möglich sein muss vorzugehen gegen Rechtsverletzungen, auch über offene Hotspots,
sondern das kann eigentlich nur bedeuten, dass Abmahnungen weiter möglich bleiben sollen.
Und das bedeutet eben, dass man offenbar die Störerhaftung dann tatsächlich doch nicht wirklich abschaffen will, sondern dass man eben nur.
Ein Teilaspekt der Störerhaftung abschaffen will. Und ähm ich weiß nicht wie weit wir jetzt hier so in die juristischen Feinheiten gehen.
Voll rein, tief rein.
Also gut, ähm, das Problem bei fangen wir mal so rum an. Das Problem eigentlich bei der Störerhaftung und das Problem am Angebot offener Hotspots,
war eigentlich immer, dass ich als Betreiber damit rechnen musste, kostenpflichtig abgemahnt zu werden für Rechtsverletzungen, die andere über diesen Weg begangen haben, also über meinen Netzzugang begangen haben.
Grundlage für eine solche Abmahnung ist immer ein Unterlassungsanspruch. Also beispielsweise der rechte Inhaber,
Sony Music oder so oder irgendwie ein anderes äh anderer Musikunternehmen. Die sagen jetzt also ähm hier ist was weiß ich, dieses und jene Pfeil
angeboten worden, illegal über diesen Zugang und jetzt verlange ich von dir WLAN-Betreiber, dass du,
Alles dafür tust, dass eine solche Rechtsverletzung in Zukunft nicht mehr vorkommt. Ja? Grundlage dafür ist eben materieller Unterlassungsanspruch,
denen die rechte Inhaber gegen die WLAN-Betreiber haben. So und den machen sie eben geltend, indem sie erstmal zum Anwalt gehen, von dem Anwalt und Abmahnschreiben verfassen lassen
Der verlangt dann in der Regel, dass dann der Betreiber auch noch eine Unterlassungserklärung abgibt und man möchte gerne eben die Kosten dann wieder haben, ne? Die Anwaltskosten, die Rechtsverfolgungskosten und so weiter.
Und.
Kurze Frage, dieser Unterlassungsanspruch basiert auf welche Gesetzesgrundlage.
Das ist eben, das ist die Störerhaftung, wenn man so möchte. Da kann ich eben in Anspruch genommen, ja, na ja, das.
Ja, ich meine, welches Gesetz wird herangezogen, um zu sagen, dass ein solcher Unterlassungsanspruch existiert. Das heißt, BGB oder was.
Nee, das ist eigentlich das Telemediengesetz, ne, was eigentlich grundsätzlich erstmal regelt, dass solche WLAN-Betreiber von der Haftung freigestellt sind und die störerhaftung selber ist dann eine Konstrukt der Rechtssprechung.
Also sozusagen nur, weil die Gerichte das so beschlossen haben, dass das so zu werten ist, aber soweit ich weiß, steht ja so ein Begriff, wie Störerhaftung und Themen gehe ja gar nicht drin.
Nein, im TMG, da steht einfach nur drin, dass diejenigen, die Dienste der Reihendurchleitung betreiben, also die nichts weiter machen als Daten über ihr System rüberzuleiten, grundsätzlich freigestellt sind von Haftungsansprüchen. Ne, und.
Alle anderen gilt dann, was auch immer, Opportun zu sein scheint und dass es dann unter anderem auch.
Ja und die Rechtssprechung sagt halt, na ja, wie weit geht denn jetzt eigentlich genau diese diese Haftungsfreistellung und die sind eben mal zu dem Ergebnis gekommen, dass es jedenfalls ist diese Haftungsfreistellung eben nicht für die Unterlassungsansprüche gilt, die die Rechtssprechung aus der Störerhafung herleite,
ja? Und ähm deswegen war es eben so, dass man damit rechnen musste als WLAN-Betreiber kostenpflichtig abgemahnt zu werden. So, also das heißt, das Kernproblem bei der Störerhaftung waren immer diese Unterlassungsansprüche. Und wenn jetzt also ähm.
Bundestagsabgeordnete eben sagen, na ja, so, ne, man muss also noch auch weiterhin möglich sein, dass die Betreiber auf Unterlassung in Anspruch genommen werden, dann lässt das ja darauf schließen, dass man offenbar genau dieses Problem nicht beheben möchte,
sondern dass man offenbar die Störerhaftung nur im Hinblick auf Schadensersatzansprüche vielleicht abschaffen möchte. So, das heißt aber eben auch, dass das, was eigentlich sich hi,
verbirgt hinter dem Begriff Abschaffung der Störerhaftung grade nicht erreicht werden wird.
Wir zumindest darunter verstehen.
Ja und das, was man als schon auch die ganze Zeit diskutiert hat, auch öffentlich, nämlich die Abschaffung des Haftungsrisikos, das dazu führt, dass die WLANs in Deutschland geschlossen bleiben.
Genau, vor allem bei
Cafés äh immer schön sichtbar, die halt am laufenden Meter, solche hinterlassungsansprüche reingesegelt bekommen, dann nicht wissen, wie sie damit umgehen sollen, häufig Strafen dann einfach zahlen oder
Belastungs, also Abmahngebühren zahlen. Ja und dann am Ende sich einfach sagen, was was soll der Geiz, warum muss ich hier Geld dafür bezahlen, anderen Leuten kostenlos was bereitzustellen.
Genau und der Hintergrund wohl für diese Entscheidung war,
Unter anderem ein Votum des Generalanwalts am EuGH. Das muss man vielleicht kurz erklären, weil das nicht jeder weiß, die Generalanwalt ist nicht etwas sowas wie ein Rechtsanwalt, sondern der ist so etwas wie ein Gerichtsgutachter
der immer am Ende eines Verfahrens, aber eben vor der eigentlichen Entscheidung des Europäischen Gerichtshofs den Verfahrensstand zusammenfasst,
und einen Entscheidungsvorschlag macht und der Gerichtshof muss diesem Entscheidungsvorschlag nicht folgen.
Tut es aber in der Regel.
Tut es aber in der Regel, genau. Und,
Es gab jetzt einen Fall von also der wo es eben kürzlich diese der Generalanwalt sein Votum abgegeben hat. McFadon gegen Sony Music
Tobias McFaden ist Veranstaltungstechniker aus Bayern, gleichzeitig Mitglied der Piratenpartei und ähm er ist abgemahnt worden, weil er ein offenes WLAN betrieben hat, nebengewerblich, neben seinem
Geschäft für Veranstaltungstechnik,
dann es da eben zu illegalen Pfeilsharing kam von irgendeinem Stück äh an dem Sony Music die Rechte hält. Sony Music hat ihn auf Unterlassung in Anspruch genommen,
Er war nicht bereit, das so zu akzeptieren, ist gerichtlich dagegen vorgegangen und hat dann eben vor dem Gericht argumentiert, dass dieses deutsche Konstrukt der Störerhaftung nicht mit europäischem Recht
vereinbar sei. Insbesondere nicht mit der E-Commerce-Richtlinie. Und dann hat sich das Gericht am Kopf gekratzt und hat gesagt, hm, ist das wirklich so?
Äh Landgericht München eins und die haben das Ganze dann im Europäischen Gerichtshof vorgelegt,
Denn immer wenn in so einem Verfahren die Frage aufkommt, ist die deutsche Rechtslage vereinbar mit der europäischen Rechtslage und es gibt dann noch keine keine keine vorherige gerichtliche Klärung drüber, dann kann so ein Gericht.
Oben geschoben und dann gibt's eine Entscheidung.
Sogenannte Vorabentscheidungsverfahren und ähm das hat das lief dann eben und der Generalanwalt hat dann eben in diesem Zusammenhang jetzt sein Votum erlassen und da hat er ihm gesagt,
Also, die Haftungsfreistellung, die sich,
In der E-Commerce-Richtlinie finde, das ist quasi die Vorgabe für das deutsche TMG. Ähm diese Haftungsfreistellung, die umfasst Schadensersatzansprüche
Das heißt, ein WLAN-Betreiber darf nie in irgendeiner Weise zu Kosten herangezogen werden, auch nicht zur Anwalts- oder Abmahnkosten. Ähm.
Und zweitens hat er eben gesagt, es muss aber möglich bleiben, dass im Falle von Rechtsverletzungen gerichtliche Unterlassungsanordnungen gemacht werden können,
So, warum? Wie kam er dazu?
Die E-Commerce-Richtlinie gibt vor, genau wie in eine andere Richtlinie die sogenannte Infosock-Richtlinie. Wir geben beide vor, dass es immer möglich bleiben muss, dass ein Gericht,
Unterlassungsanordnung treffen können muss gegen einen WLAN-Betreiber zum Beispiel. Ähm,
Das darf jetzt aber nicht verwechselt werden mit der Frage, ob der rechte Inhaber gegen den WLAN-Betreiber einen materiellen Unterlassungsanspruch hat. Das sind zwei verschiedene Dinge. Das eine ist die Frage, kann ein Gericht, ein WLAN-Betreiber befehlen,
Ergreife jetzt bitte diese und jene Maßnahme, damit Rechtsverletzungen in der Zukunft nicht mehr vorkommen. Und die andere Frage ist, ob der Rechtsinhaber, also das Musiklabel oder so, materiell einen Anspruch hat,
Gegen den WLAN-Betreiber, was er zum Beispiel im Wege der Abmahnung geltend machen könn.
So und ganz klipp und klar, der Generalanwalt sagt in seinem Votum lediglich, es müssen gerichtliche Unterlassungsanordnungen möglich bleiben und genauso steht das auch in den europäischen Vorschriften selber drin.
In der großen Koalition ist man jetzt offenbar aber eher zu dem Ergebnis gekommen und das entspricht auch so ein bisschen der deutschen, rechtsdogmatischen Denke.
Da wo es eine gerichtliche Unterlassungsanordnung gibt, da muss es auch einen zugrunde liegenden materiellen Unterlassungsanspruch geben und das ist keineswegs so,
ja? Das ist typischerweise so, zugegebenermaßen, aber sogar im deutschen Recht gibt's Beispiele dafür, wo es anders ist.
Das Gewaltschutzgesetz. Ja, im Gewalt da geht's um Fälle von häuslicher Gewalt. So und da hat das, ist ein relativ kurzes Gesetz und danach hat das Gericht die Möglichkeit, in Fällen von häuslicher Gewalt Anordnung gegen den Aggressor.
Zu erlassen. Also beispielsweise, dass sie die gemeinsame Wohnung nicht mehr betreten darf oder bestimmten Abstand einhalten muss und so weiter und so fort. Und Grundlage dafür ist lediglich ein Antrag,
Der oder des Betroffenen. Ja, aber was nicht damit verbunden ist, dass sich irgendeinen konkreten materiellen Anspruch geltend mache, ja? Ich muss also nicht hingehen und sagen,
Ich al
Betroffene, Betroffene, habe jetzt irgendwie gegen den oder die Aggressorin ähm einen Anspruch darauf, dass sie mich nicht mehr verletzt und den setze ich jetzt gerichtlich durch, sondern ich gehe einfach zum Gericht und sage, es hat hier einen Fall von häuslicher Gewalt gegeben, das soll in Zukunft nicht mehr vorkommen und dann
trifft das Gericht, diejenigen Anordnungen, die notwendig sind, um das sicherzustellen,
Und genauso könnte man das, wenn man wirklich wollte, auch im Fall von WLAN-Hotspots machen, ja? Man könnte genauso regeln, dass eben in diesen Fällen es möglich ist, eine gerichtliche Anordnung zu beantragen, bei denen auch der WLAN-Betreiber hinterher nicht die Kosten trägt, auch das, wie gesagt,
verlangt ja der Generalanwalt.
Und dann muss man eben sehen, welche Maßnahmen das im Einzelnen sein könnten. Aber damit hätte man jedenfalls das Problem gelöst, dass man sich in die Gefahr einer kostenpflichtigen Abmahnung begibt, in dem Moment, wo man sein WLAN aufmach.
Mhm. Also man könnte immer noch vom Gericht eine Anordnung bekommen, irgendwelche Maßnahmen zu ergreifen. Etsperren, andere äh Dinge kommen natürlich da gleich auch wieder äh hoch.
Nochmal im Einzelnen drüber reden, weil auch dazu hat sich der Generalanwalt dann noch geäußert, er hat auch gesagt, dass es einige Maßnahmen gibt, die definitiv nicht zumutbar sind, ne? Und dazu gehört zum Beispiel eine Passwortsicherung, dazu gehört zum Beispiel, dass wir dann komplett dicht zu machen,
Das wären alles so Lösungen, die nicht gehen, ne? Er hatte nicht also nicht gemacht hat ist, dass er explizit gesagt hat, was denn zulässige Maßnahmen werden. Da werden nur mal beispielhaft aufgeführt, was jedenfalls unzumutbar wäre,
Aber das ist dann eine Frage, also man muss sich natürlich auch die Frage stellen, hat der eigentlich überhaupt tatsächlich die Möglichkeit, solche Rechtsverletzungen in Zukunft zu verhindern
ja? Also es muss auch immer im Rahmen des zumutbaren sich bewegen. Aber das wäre dann eine Frage sozusagen des Gerichts, wo die sich überlegen müssen, wie gestalten wir denn jetzt genau im Einzelfall eine solche Anordnung? Eine andere Frage ist eben, wie man abstrakt
Rechtslage gestaltet, um eben auf der einen Seite dem Interesse daran Rechtsverletzungen vorzubeugen, gerecht zu werden, auf der anderen Seite aber eben auch wirklich offene,
WLAN-Netze zu ermöglichen.
Ähm wir reden ja nach wie vor nur von der publizierten Einschätzung des EU-Generalanwalts. Es gab noch keine EuGH Entscheidung dazu. Auch wenn man davon ausgeht, dass sie dem im Wesentlichen folgen dürfte, ist ja noch nicht da,
Vielleicht ist das auch so ein Grund, dass hier noch ein bisschen Eiertanz äh möglich ist. Wann ist damit zu rechnen? Finalen Entscheidung.
Kann man schwer sagen, also alles zwischen zwei und sechs Monaten ist denkbar.
Okay, aber in diesem Jahr.
Wahrscheinlich noch in diesem Jahr, aber wahrscheinlich eben nicht mehr vor dem Termin äh im Plenum am zweiten Juno. Das halte ich eher für unwahrscheinlich.
Und der Termin bewirkt was, das ist dann die Entscheidung über die Gesetzesnovelle, von der man heute noch nicht weiß, wie sie aussieht, aber wo man äh ausgehen kann, dass es sie schon, dass sie irgendjemand schon mal aufgeschrieben hat.
Genau, das ist zweite und dritte Lesung dann und da wird tatsächlich dieses Gesetz dann beschlossen, verabschiedet und dann genau, gehen wir also dann fehlt eben nur noch danach die Ausfertigung durch den Bundespräsidenten und die Veröffentlichung und dann äh ist.
Dann muss der Gesetzestext nicht schon bei der ersten Lesung, ich meine, wenn man's lesen will.
Ja, den gab's ja auch ursprünglich. Also.
Aber nur, dass der jetzt wieder geändert wurde.
Genau, also ursprünglich war es ja so im im März, zwanzig fünfzehn hat die Bundesregierung, beziehungsweise also, ne, ähm unter Federführung des BMWI ähm einen Entwurf vorgelegt für eine Änderung des TMG.
Das hat extrem viel Kritik erfahren, dann haben die diesen Entwurf nochmal ein klein bisschen geändert, nachdem eben von, also fast geschlossen, Kritik
kam, also bis auf ganz ganz wenige so Leute wie Waldorf Roma, die hätten's gerne noch,
bisschen schärfer gehabt, aber eigentlich alle anderen Verbraucherschützer, Einzelhandelsverband und so weiter und zwar haben wir alle durch die Bank gesagt, das geht nicht, ist europarechtswidrig, soll nicht praktikabel, denn da waren eben immer noch vorgesehen, Passwortsicherung, Vorschaltseite und so
Wie gesagt, der Entwurf wurde minimal nochmal verändert, ging dann aber auch
des Notifizierungsverfahren bei der Europäischen Kommission, ne? Immer wenn man so als Nationalstaat Regeln macht für Dienste der Informationsgesellschaft, dann kann man die nicht einfach so machen, ne? Sondern muss die in die sogenannte Tristotifizierung geben, das heißt, man gibt es einmal der Europäischen Kommission, die guckt sich dann an
sind die Pläne mit dem Binnenmarkt vereinbar, ist das Ganze mit dem europäischen Recht vereinbar,
Da gab's dann interessanterweise, also das dauert so drei Monate, da gab's am Ende eine Einschätzung der Kommission, die eigentlich zu dem Ergebnis kam, das geht nicht, ist alles Europa rechtswidrig,
Diese Einschätzung, die wurde aber also doch nicht,
großräumig zirkuliert sagen wir mal. Also das war tatsächlich so, dass lange Zeit auch selbst viele Bundestagsabgeordnete diese Einschätzung nicht kannten und eigentlich immer dachten, die Kommission hätte keine Einwände, ne
gab's danach auch noch im Dezember eine Sachverständigenanhörung im Bundestag, wo dann nochmal ganz deutlich selbst von den Sachverständigen von
Union und SPD gesagt wurde, das, was ihr da vorhabt, ist Europarechtswidriges nicht vereinbar mit der E-Commerce-Richtlinie.
Da war dann auf einmal die Überraschung groß, obwohl viele, wie auch wir zum Beispiel, dass also zu dem Zeitpunkt schon fast ein Jahr lang, äh, so gesagt hätten, aber
man hat sich da offenbar nicht mit auseinandersetzen wollen und dann waren die Kopfschmerzen so ein bisschen groß, ähm so über die Weihnachtsferien, über den Jahreswechsel hinweg, wie man denn jetzt eigentlich weitermacht. Und da waren eigentlich die Verhandlungen komplett festgefahren und irgendwann dann Ende Februar,
Dieses Jahres hat man sich dann drauf geeinigt zu sagen, ach, jetzt warten wir einfach mal ab, was der.
Was der EuGH dazu sagt, ne? Also wenn wir als Gesetzgeber mit unserer Gestaltungsmacht,
kommen da irgendwie nicht zurecht. Jetzt lassen wir uns das Ganze mal vom EuGH vortanzen,
Und dann machen wir das genauso wie die sagen. Also das tatsächlich war es so, dass da da war eigentlich überhaupt gar kein, gar kein Fortkommen mehr. Jedenfalls ähm in der ganz, also im äh September war das Mitte September.
Zwanzig fünfzehn wurde eben dieser Gesetzentwurf in den Bundestag eingebracht, dann gab's auch ähm die erste Lesung. Wie gesagt, danach ging's dann in den
Wirtschaftsausschuss, wo auch die Sachverständigenanhörungen stattgefunden hat und ab da hing das Ding da eigentlich und jetzt die Frage, wie geht's eben weiter? Und tatsächlich will man's eben offenbar jetzt verändern, wie ganz genau,
weiß man noch nicht, kann man nur erahnen und dann soll jetzt aber ganz schnell zweite und dritte Lesung im Plenum kommen, was natürlich ein bisschen blöd ist, den Ball letztlich,
zu dem Entwurf, der dann jetzt verabschiedet werden soll, hat's ja eigentlich gerade keine wirkliche Verbändeanhörung und Ähnliches gegeben. Und genau diese Problematik, die ich eben versucht habe zu beschreiben, ne, Stichwort Unterlassungsanordnung, Unterlassungsanspruch
die bleibt eigentlich unerartert bisher im Raum stehen und es gibt nur vereinzelte Stimmen so aus dem bürgerrechtlichen Bereich,
da jetzt mal ein bisschen draufdrücken und sagen, hallo, hier ist aber noch ein Problem und,
ne, das ist ein großer PR-Kuh bisher. Man schreibt ganz laut, wir machen die Abschaffung der Störerhaftung und tatsächlich macht man's gar nicht.
Das ist echt und und diese aber ist das üblich so ein Gesetzestext so lange unter Verschluss zu halten, schon irgendwie.
Vollzug zu äh zu feiern ohne dass das Ding jemals jemand gesehen hat, dass es nicht unbedingt übliches Vorgehen, oder?
Nö, aber wäre das anders, dann äh könnte man wahrscheinlich auch nicht so gut feiern.
Also ich glaube, ich nehme mal an, dass das tatsächlich der der Grund ist, warum man das so macht,
weil man sich das jetzt nicht zerreden lassen möchte, ne? Weil sie ganz genau wissen, es gibt halt Leute, die da sehr genau draufschauen, die eben eine ganz konkrete Vorstellung davon haben, wie das denn aussehen sollte mit Abschaffung der Schörerhaftung,
Und es hat ja jetzt ohnehin schon so lange gedauert und jetzt hat Kanzlerin Merkel die Augen auf den Tisch gehauen. Also muss es jetzt irgendwie schnell durch.
Und dann macht man es vielleicht auf diese Art und Weise. Also anders kann ich mir das auch nicht erklären. Ich wüsste nicht wirklich, wenn man, wenn man, also wenn es tatsächlich darum ging, eine gute Lösung zu finden, eine, die wasserdicht ist, eine, die tatsächlich auch das bewirkt, was sie bewirken soll, nämlich eben flächendeckend offenes WLAN,
hätte man sich da vielleicht eher eine sachliche Auseinandersetzung begeben und genau das ist eben offensichtlich nicht passiert und also ich finde, da ist der Interpretationsspielraum, warum das jetzt so ist, relativ.
Was erwartest du denn, was jetzt passiert? Also hast du wie so ein Bauchgefühl, dass dass sich da jetzt irgendein.
Irgendjemand mal das Hirn einschaltet und dann dann einfach mal das Richtige tut oder denkst du, da wird jetzt noch weiter rumgeeiert.
Na, ich glaube also, das hat nicht so viel mit Hirneinschalten zu tun, sondern äh das ist glaube ich ganz absichtlich so gemacht
ne? Das hat nämlich auch damit zu tun, dass man natürlich jetzt zum Beispiel von der Unionsseite, die ja traditionell relativ enge Beziehungen zu Oberrechtsindustrie pflegt, ähm! Sagen kann, ähm! Ne, also wir hätten ja eigentlich das gerne ganz anders gehabt,
wir hätten's ja eigentlich gerne mit Registrierung und so weiter gehabt. War leider europarechtlich nicht mehr auf zurechtzuerhalten, aber wir haben letztlich gekämpft, wie die Löwen
und haben rausgeholt, was rauszuholen ist und seid mal beruhigt, wenigstens die Unterlassungsansprüche bleiben. Also, ihr könnt weiter abmahnen, alles cool.
Ne? Und also ich glaube, dass es äh Absicht, dass man das so macht. Also ich kann mir das nicht anders erklären, weil es ist ja nicht so, dass sie, glaube ich, dieses rechtliche Verständnis nicht wirklich haben, sondern äh das.
Konkret Daten, ich würde schon sagen, da steht ein ganz konkreter Plan hinterher.
Also kurz gesagt, man muss weiterhin aufmerksam bleiben und wenn jetzt der äh Vorschlag, der jetzt für die zweite Lesung vorgelegt wird, nach wie vor Unterlassungsansprüche zulassen würde, gilt es weiterhin auf diesen Vorschlag einzuhauen, weil sich ja im Prinzip dann nichts ändert.
Ja, jedenfalls auf diesen Gesichtspunkt. Genau, also.
Ich meine, was würde sich denn überhaupt ändern, wenn das jetzt immer noch drin bleiben würde, also.
Ja, das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Ich glaube, die Hoffnung in Anführungsstrichen liegt dann auf den Gerichten
nicht wahr? Also der Gesetzgeber kommt seiner Gestaltungsaufgabe nur so bedingt nach, ne? Das Einzige, was sie wahrscheinlich dann machen werden, ist eben zu sagen, okay, wir stellen eben WLAN-Betreiber mit klassischen Access Providern gleich.
Aber schreiben eben nicht rein, dass sich diese Haftungsfreistellung äh auch auf Unterlassungsansprüche bezieht. Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht in dem Gesetz drinstehen und ähm dann wird man eben hoffen.
Dass wenn dann der nächste Abmahnungsfall kommt und der vor Gericht geht, dass die Gerichte dann,
im Kopf haben, dass es die Entscheidung des EuGH gibt und die dann eben im Rahmen der Interpretation und Anwendung des deutschen Rechts mit heranziehen, das müssen sie nämlich dann auch und äh dann,
hoffentlich sagen, aha, daraus ergibt sich aber auch Unterlassungsansprüche, sollten eigentlich miterfasst sein oder so.
Ist eine der politische Begriff störerhaftung jetzt hier in der im politischen Diskurs noch ausreichend oder müsste man den nicht mal in gewisser Hinsicht etwas präzisieren.
Na ja, wenn jetzt sozusagen gesagt wird, na ja, wir schaffen jetzt die Störerhaftung ab, aber ach so, Unterlassungsansprüche, na ja, da davon war ja nicht die Rede, ja? Also äh.
Ja, also im im.
Ist ja in der Luft, ne?
Ja, in der politischen Auseinandersetzung ganz klar, muss man eben sagen, also ne, das ist dann schon eher eine Mogelpackung, wenn man sagt, man würde die Störerhaftung abschaffen, genau das tut man dann ja jedenfalls nicht konsequent.
Also was das natürlich schon mal gut ist, ist, dass man sich offenbar, so wie es ausschaut, eben verabschiedet hat von Passwortsicherung verabschiedet hat, von Vorschaltseite und so, was natürlich auch völlig ilusorische,
Ideen eigentlich waren, ne, das da überhaupt reinzuschreiben. Alleine, also diese Vorschaltseite, wo bis heute irgendwie niemand weiß.
Wie das ernsthaft funktionieren soll, dass dadurch Rechtsverletzungen ähm vorgebeugt wird, ja?
Fällt mir mal wieder so ein so ein altes Zitat-Cover ein aus sechsundachtzigern. Bonn rettet den Wald und dann Wald mit einem Schildrand, Waldsterben verboten, ja.
Also, ne, ich ich versuche das immer so deutlich zu machen, wer ernsthaft meint, dass so eine Vorschalzeit irgendein sinnvolles Mittel wäre um Rechtsverletzungen zu vermeiden, der muss auch sagen, dass die Altersabfrage bei Juporn eine effektive Maßnahme des Jugendschutzes ist.
Hast du da mal weiter geklickt.
Bin aber nicht dran vorbeigekommen.
Ah M.
Also es ergibt halt einfach wenig Sinn, aber tatsächlich die Vorstellung auch gerade so in der in der konservativen Politik
und das wurde auch immer wieder im Rahmen dann so so der Verhandlung im Hintergrund geäußert. Äh ist halt äh dass man sagt, na ja ähm wenn die Leute also völlig unbeobachtet äh unterwegs sind, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch, dass sie Straftaten begehen werden, dass sie sich rechtswidrig verhalten werden und so weiter. Und wenn man so eine rechts äh äh
treue Erklärung da abgegeben hat auf einer Vorschaltseite und eben gesagt hat ich werde jetzt hier mich ordnungsgemäß verhalten, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit also hoch,
auch tatsächlich tun werden. Also Normbefolgung durch Paranoia ist so das Konzept offenbar.
Ja, ein letzter äh
noch Udo Vettert in seinem Blog in seinem Loreblock auch nochmal gesagt selbst wenn die Unterlassungsansprüche tatsächlich eingestampft werden würden, wozu er sich glaube ich jetzt gar nicht weiter geäußert hat, aber
das halt wahrscheinlich ansieht oder nicht. Wer sowieso alles noch ganz furchtbar, weil ähm also man wäre sozusagen immer noch nicht raus aus dem Risiko,
wegen Kipo, wegen einer Pornografie oder der Verbreitung von
Dokumentiert Kindesmissbrauch, je nachdem welche Sprachregelung man dort bevorzugt und ähm wird auch noch weiter aus, dass ja,
Tauschszene sich ja bisher weitgehend über das Tornetzwerk abgeschottet habe, es hier aber im zunehmenden Maße auch Kompromisierung äh gibt, über welche Wege auch immer, sodass eben auch dort Ermittlungserfolge
erzielt werden würden, würden aber sozusagen nun diese Tauschszene sich an diese neu gewundene Freiheit offener WLANs annehmen
dann hätte man immer noch das Problem
dass die Behörden gerne bei solchen Ermittlungen über ermittelte IP-Adressen schnell mal eine Hausdurchsuchung einleiten, bevor irgendwelche weiteren
Fragen gefragt werden und dann eben alle damit rechnen müssen, dass am laufenden Mittag irgendwelche Rechner rausgetragen werden. Hallo diese Sichtweise in irgendeiner Form.
Na ja, also ich glaube nicht, dass das Problem tatsächlich so groß ist, wie wie er das hier aufwirft. Also zunächst mal
Geld, der diese Haftungsfreistellung im Paragraphen acht TMG ähm auch für für Strafrecht und nicht nur fürs Zivilrecht
ne? Ähm dann kommt hinzu, dass strafbar natürlich immer nur derjenige ist, der auch tatsächlich mit dem entsprechenden Vorsatz in der Regel ähm die eigentliche Straftat begangen hat
Ne, also eine Zurechnung von Straftaten gibt also nur sehr bedingt bei Mittätern, bei Gehilfen
also zu sagen, dass jemand, der einen offenen WLAN-Hotspot betreibt, jetzt
Beihilfe konkret zur Verbreitung von Kinderpornografie, zum Beispiel leistet, ähm finde ich doch schon sehr gewagt, weil er da in der Regel überhaupt gar keinen Vorsatz in diese Richtung.
Also ich meine, ist was anderes natürlich, wenn da zwei Kolossiv zusammenwirken und sich verabreden, um sowas zu machen. Aber so der Normalfall, von dem wir jetzt reden,
WLAN-Betreiber macht einfach für die Allgemeinheit sein WLAN auf und irgendjemand missbraucht es eben dann dafür, um solche Straftaten zu begehen, ähm dann haftet er erstmal überhaupt nicht dafür.
Natürlich ist es nicht ganz falsch, was der Väter sagt, ähm nämlich, dass die Gefahr besteht, dass die Behörden zunächst mal ein Ermittlungsverfahren einleiten
und im Zuge dessen dann eben auch eine Hausdurchsuchung erfolgen kann. Das ist theoretisch durchaus denkbar
Allerdings wenn den Behörden bekannt ist, dass es sich um offenen WLAN-Hotspot handelt,
dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit glaube ich doch wieder eher sehr gering. Also es gab ähnliche Fälle mal ähm.
Im Zusammenhang mit dem House Provider auch hier, da hat das Kammergericht Berlin darüber entschieden und haben eben auch das war zweitausendvierzehn ganz klar gesagt, nein, die haften nicht auch nicht in strafrechtlicher Hinsicht, ich glaube damals ging's irgendwie um die Verbreitung volksverhetzender Äußerungen
und ähm also die sind dafür überhaupt gar nicht verantwortlich
können dafür auch strafrechtlich eigentlich gar nicht herangezogen werden und da war es dann auch so, dass die Staatsanwaltschaft dann,
Also die die haben dieses, äh, die haben die Klage da noch nicht mal zugelassen, ja, in dem Fall,
Also die Staatsanwaltschaft wollte zwar gerne was machen, das Gericht hat dann auch gleich gesagt, nee, nee, also in solchen Fällen ähm das das führt irgendwohin, es kann auch gar nicht zu einer Verurteilung führen haben, deswegen das Verfahren noch nicht zugelassen. A.
Hausdurchsuchung sind ja die eigentliche Bedrohung, dass die einfach erstmal stattfinden, ne?
Sicher, nur wenn die Staatsanwaltschaft von vornherein weiß, dass in solchen Fällen es ohnehin nicht zur zur zu einer Anklage kommen wird. Und einfach die das Verfahren gar nicht zugelassen wird vom Gericht, dann warum sollten sie dann vorher solche Maßnahmen machen? Das ergibt ja wenig Sinn,
Ich sag ja theoretisch ist das zwar schon denkbar die praktische Relevanz halte ich eher für für nicht so allzu hoch.
Also es passiert ja auch jetzt nicht, zum Beispiel bei bei irgendwelchen Hotspots von Kabel Deutschland oder so. Äh ist ja auch nicht so, dass wenn da also
Abgesehen davon, dass eigentlich da so gut wie keine Rechtsverletzungen begangen werden dadrüber, aber selbst in den Fällen passiert das meines Wissens auch nicht wirklich, dass da äh Hausdurchsuchungen gemacht werden, gerade wenn man weiß, dass sich ohnehin bei der IP-Adresse um Hotspot handelt.
Aber ist nicht ähm also der ist ja schon ein Unterschied, wenn ich jetzt ein äh.
Wenn die jetzt sehen, okay, ist eine Kabel Deutschland äh oder ist eine IP-Adresse. So und dann gucken die, okay, die gehört Kabel Deutschland. Und dann wird Kabel Deutschland sagen, hey, dieser IP ist einer von unseren Hotspots. Und dann ist der, dann ist der Nutzer ja auch registriert, ne? Dann wissen die ja, mit welchem Login der da drin war.
Wenn's ein offener Hotspot ist, nicht.
Nee, ist halt nicht, das ist ja sozusagen dann nur für Kunden. Da kommen wir äh im Übrigen eh gleich im zweiten Teil noch.
Offen. Ach so, nee, die haben offen, ne? Ja, ja, die haben so halbe Stunde offen.
Es gab hier ähm doch auch diesen diesen Pilot, dieses Pilot, dieses Pilotprojekt von Kabel Deutschland, wo die hier in Berlin-Brandenburg, ich weiß nicht, wie viel hundert offene Hotspots hat.
Gut, ich meine, es gibt natürlich tonnenweise auch Telekom und zwar äh Bahn, Züge, Netze, also man muss nicht überall äh zwangsläufig angemeldet sein, das.
Nee, das so. Ja, ja, die sind, das gibt eigentlich relativ viele, wo man nicht angewendet ist, das stimmt schon, ja.
Ja ich muss da ein wenig äh äh kriechern, als ich jetzt das Argument von äh Udo Vetter sah und gleichzeitig halt noch die Ankündigung der freien äh der evangelischen Kirche, frei frei ist sie glaube ich nicht, neue vangelische Kirche, aber das WLAN soll frei sein, was sie in Ihren Kirchen anbieten.
Der Gottspot.
So mal gespannt, wie die sich dann gegen die Keepo äh.
Ja, die brauchen doch nur den offenen Weg. Ach so, nee, das war die Katholiken.
Gott sieht ohnehin alles insofern,
Aber da gab's ein interessantes Interview noch mit äh Fabian Kretschmer, Kretschmann, dem ähm IT-Verantwortlichen der evangelischen Kirche, der auch für dieses Projekt äh zuständig ist, bei bei Spiegel Online,
und darauf gab's dann schon so ein, zwei Punkte, die ich ganz äh interessant fand, die sich also ursprünglich in der Ankündigung dann doch anders lassen, also,
Seid ihr geheißen? Es findet da keinerlei Überwachung statt, es werden keine persönen bezogenen Daten gespeichert oder so. In dem Interview sagt er dann, na ja, also falls dann Leute sich da pornografie
allgemein, Pornografie oder ähnliches drüber runterladen, dann müsste man vielleicht schon darüber nachdenken, ob man noch Inhaltsfilter installieren würde. Wie,
Aber jetzt die Kirche eigentlich wissen will, ob sich Leute Pornografie darüber runterladen, wenn sie ja gerade diesen Zugang nicht überwachen. Das ist mir ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht klar, wie das zusammenpasst. Und eine andere interessante Gesichtspomm.
Moin im Moment, das ist doch, das ist doch von der Kirche, also das heißt ja auch Gottspot, das heißt Gott alles sieht alles und ähm der wird dann schon die äh Padrissen rausrücken dann, ne?
So wird's sein, ganz genau, ne? Ähm, himmlisch. So und also das ist ein Gesichtspunkt, der den dich also so ein bisschen unverständlich fand, ein anderer Gesichtspunkt, den ich auch.
Sagen wir mal so ein bisschen zum Schmunzeln fand äh der in diesem Interview erwähnt wurde, war eben die Frage, ob das denn nicht die Gläubigen beim Gottesdienst ablenken könne, wenn sie äh WLAN-Zugang haben. Ich nenne mir al.
An der alle mit dem Smart.
Mit dem Smartphone in der Messe oder so,
weiß ich, ja? Und äh jedenfalls äh da wird dann gesagt, na deswegen soll ein Fahrer dann die Möglichkeit bekommen, manuell es dann dann auch mal auszuschalten, ne? Dann gibt's halt mal sonntags zwischen zehn und zwölf halt mal
WLAN oder man kann automatisches Sperrzeiten programmieren.
Na die, ich meine, die Priester sind im Prinzip, die sind schon immer der Proxi zu Gott gewesen, damit sind sie natürlich auch äh in dem Moment halt der Proxi auch zum,
WLAN, wenn man darüber sozusagen jetzt eigentlich, wenn das jetzt der moderne Weg ist, Gott zu erreichen, da fragt sich natürlich nur, welche IP-Adresse hat Gott,
spricht ja auch IP vor sechs.
Punkt null Punkt null.
Der ist das.
Wusstest du nicht?
Ich habe da immer keinen Pink gekriegt, aber ich bin auch so furchtbar unreligiös.
Dann glauben, dann kommt der.
Oh Mann, die Route stellt sich dann automatisch ein.
Das ganz ähm ah ich finde das doch eigentlich ganz schön, lass die doch also sag mal prinzipiell finde ich es ja erstmal gut, wenn irgendjemand irgendwo Interne.
Nein, ich finde das auch. Das wollte ich damit auch gar nicht sagen. Wir witzeln nur ein bisschen rum. Ich finde das äh super, dass sie das machen, aber äh die Idee jetzt ausgerechnet die Konzentration, dadurch steigern zu wollen, indem man den Netzzugang dann abschaltet, ist natürlich äh.
Ja, da hast du auf jeden Fall die Aufmerksamkeit des Publikums, der Gemein.
Na ja es wurde ja auch immer betont, dass das Ganze eben nicht nur für Angehörige der evangelischen Kirche sei, sondern eben auch für für Personen, die nicht in der Kirche sind, äh nutzbar sein soll, weil das ja auch ein Angebot zur Kommunikation sein solle und so weiter. Ähm
Dazu finde ich, passt dann aber genau sowas nicht, dass man ausgerechnet während der Messezeiten dann äh das WLAN abschaltet. Das sind ganz merkwürdige Idee, aber.
Gott hat einfach Vor.
Das war aber einfach so ein Interview, oder?
Genau. Also es war nicht die Presse mit, die Pressemitteilung las ich natürlich noch ein bisschen anders, aber das waren dann eben so Einzelheiten, die dann erst in dem Interview.
Da haben sie den Mann vielleicht ein bisschen in eine Falle äh rasseln lassen. Ob die jetzt irgendwie so den roten Internetnot ausknopf auf ihre äh Kanzel bekommen oder ich kenne mich leider mit Kirchen nicht so gut aus, aber ich weiß.
Ich auch nicht.
Gibt dabei irgendwie, wo die Wein haben oder so, einen Knopf.
Ne, die Kanzler, das ist so quasi da der Hauptrouter und so muss man sich das, glaube ich, denken. Also Kirche.
Das Kreuz ist die Antenne.
Ist auch eigentlich nichts anderes als so ein großes Netzwerk.
Und die Heiligen Scheine über den antiken Malereien werden dann in so WLAN-Symbole geänder.
Da können wir dann immer sehen, irgendwie umso mehr man glaubt, umso mehr Netz gibt's dann auch.
Ja, du hast doch hier dieses analoge Bandbreitenmessgerät, das könntest du dir noch schwimmen, dann sieht man so eine Halleluja, wenn er dann am Ende anschließ.
Okay. Ich finde das gut und ich möchte äh so die Kirchen sind ja traditionell im Besitz ähm hoher Gebäude.
Und ich weiß, dass sie hier in ähm Berlin zum Beispiel auch einen signifikanten und nicht nur in Berlin, in vielen anderen Freifunkstädten auch äh Signifikanten ähm,
Teil der der Richtfunkfern äh Verstreckung von Freifunk und zwar schon seit weiß ich nicht wie viel Jahren äh betreiben.
Da gibt's äh da ist Aufgeschlossenheit auf jeden Fall.
Ja, weil irgendwelche Leute, weil dann die Pfeifunka eben dann sagen, hier komm, pass mal auf, da oben eine Turm. Braucht ihr doch eigentlich nicht. Äh wir hängen da mal äh ein paar Antennen dran. Das ist hier durchaus das Ding. Wäre für mich auch den, die damals die nächste Note gewesen.
Aber okay, das ist wirklich so eine frei, sicher und Kirche.
Genau. Für äh alle Ungläubigen da draußen äh bleibt euch nur Lokbuch Netzpolitik als Zugang zur Erlösung. Oder Freifunk, genau. Ähm ja. Ja, ich denke,
mehr können wir jetzt erstmal auch gar nicht sagen zur Styrohaftung, ich fasse kurz zusammen, äh nichts genaues weiß man nicht, äh es ist unklar, ob wir jetzt die äh eigentlich erhoffte Abschaffung dessen, was wir Störerhaftung nennen, äh erhalten oder ob sozusagen nur eine andere Variante, die von anderen Leuten so genannt wird, äh durchgesetzt werden wird,
das wird dann im Juni sich abzeichnen und wir werden das weiter kritisch äh begleiten.
Wo wir das gerade eben schon äh hatten, wir bleiben bei den äh Hotspots und zwar bei den von Kabel.
Kabel, ne, nicht Kabel Deutschland, oder? Von.
United Unity Media.
Ist dasselbe, ne? Oder? Ich liege bei diesen ganzen ähm Sachen schon nicht mehr durch. Äh kannst du mir mal kurz.
Unity Media ist äh ist eine die Kabelanbieter. Mhm. Der ähm auch Internet macht. Also über Kabelinternet, ne? Und die haben.
Hat also mit Kabel Deutschland nichts zu tun, habe ich mich jetzt gerade äh verlesen. Genau.
Und die haben ähm etwas gemacht, was ich, was sie ja eigentlich als Idee, ich glaube, das hatte ich hier vor einiger Zeit auch schon mal so gesagt, eigentlich als Idee ganz.
Ganz gut finde, also ganz naheliegend. Und zwar haben die ja ihre äh ihre Kunden da sitzen, die Kunden haben ein,
Router zu Hause stehen, der Ruther macht ein WLAN-Signal. Und dann haben die sich gesagt, ja, pass auf. Dieser Router, der jetzt bei dir zu Hause steht, der macht einfach noch ein zweites WLAN auf, dieses WLAN heißt dann Unity Media äh Hotspot,
oder wie auch immer, ne? Und da machen wir ähm Hotspot-Betrieb drüber. Und wenn du selber diesen, diesen Hotspotdienst,
bei dir in deiner
Wohnung duldest, dann äh kommst du auch in dessen Genuss, wenn du woanders bist, ne? Also Hotspot to go haben sie das. Ah nee, WLAN to go haben sie's dann auch irgendwie äh
Ne, WLAN to go heißt es bei der Telekom. Ähm irgendwie sowas, ne? Also die die Idee einfach eine ein flächendeckendes Hotspot Netz aufzubauen, das aus den Wohnzimmern der Leute funkt. Hat natürlich für den.
Anbieter selber, einige,
wichtige Vorteile zum Beispiel, dass sie, wenn sie das machen, keine Stromrechnung und keine Gebäude oder Anschlussplatz Mieten zahlen müssen für ihre Hotspot-Infrastruktur. Ähm.
Sondern dass einfach relativ einfach eben flächendeckend hochziehen können. Und sie haben ein weiteres,
Produkt, was ihren Kunden äh bewerben können, nämlich diese äh WLAN-Flatrate, Hotspot Flatrate, die man daraus hat. Ähm eigentlich erstmal keine
so blöde Idee. Selbstverständlich wird das dann irgendwie geschlossen und die traden ihre Nutzer und du hast einen Account und du musst dich anmelden, also alles, was an Hotspot schlecht ist, ähm gibt's natürlich auch da.
Ist die Frage, wie das konkret äh jetzt gelöst ist bei Ihnen bei ihren Unitymedia, weiß ich nicht, ob Sie sozusagen auch eine Authentifizierung über die die SIM-Karte zum Beispiel ermöglichen.
Ja, das gibt's genau, das ich das glaube ich nicht, dass sie das können, weil die ja gar keine Sinn was ausgeben.
Weil sie sozusagen selber nicht,
SIM-Karte sind wir best bei Telekom ist. Das heißt, dann sind sie quasi gezwungen, so einen automatischen Anmelde äh Prozess zu machen und wenn der halt nicht transparent ist, sondern eben irgendwie mit Splash Grien und so weiter, dann ist das schon mal nervig genug. Insbesondere, wenn du glücklich,
äh glücklich irgendwie mit deinem Telefon durch die Straßen marschierst, äh perfektes LTE hast und dann äh.
WLAN.
Dann dann wechselt der in so ein blödes WLAN rein, wo man erstmal interagieren muss, dann ist ja sozusagen alles noch viel schlechter. Also ich bin da nur so sehr begrenzter Freund. Interessant fand ich ja auch noch so die Aussage
das ist ja den Kunden überhaupt nicht schaden würde, weil ja die Bandbreite nicht von dem Kontingent des Kunden abgeht. Was ich insofern sehr lustig finde, weil man beim Kabel.
Provider ohnehin ein Sheld-Medium hat, was man sich mit allen anderen teilt und wenn da sozusagen Bandbreite nicht weggenommen wird, dann wird sie wahrscheinlich schon vorher weggenommen. Das heißt, die Gesamtbandbreite, die allen Nutzern zur Verfügung steht, ist schon mal eingeschränkt, um eben für diesen öffentlichen Zugang,
Platz zu äh freizuhalten und damit ist natürlich sehr wohl eine Einschränkung äh da.
Der ja, aber die wäre auch da, wenn die einfachen Kunden mehr halten. Ja, also ich.
Landwirts reserviert ist, dann ist es sozusagen selbst im im besten Fall, also selbst äh wenn dieser Kunde da ist, aber nichts tut, kann ich diese na ja, das sagen sie ja, das ist sozusagen nicht davon ab.
Die kommt magisch irgendwo her. Das ist wie, das ist wie so ein wie so ein Spezialdienst, ne? Nimmt keinem was weg, kostet nichts
aber ist halt äh schneller und reservierte, also
Ich sag nur die Idee als solche finde ich technisch erstmal gar nicht so blöd, ne? Und wenn das dann irgendwie solche wenn das so Unternehmen machen wie die deutsche Telekom, die auch über SIM-Karten verfügen oder in Frankreich macht das SFR, weiß ich nicht seit wie vielen Jahren
dann macht das Ding eben so ein WLAN auf, was weiß ich, SFR äh minus,
RP Sim und da können dann halt die Telefone buchen sich dann eben auch automatisch da ein, authentifizieren sich mit der SIM-Karte, sparst du dir als Betreiber eine Menge ähm,
eine Menge Infrastrukturen kosten. Na ja, Unity Media hat gesagt, ja, geil, machen wir auch. Hier zack, liebe Kunden, guck mal. Hier ist der Softwareupdate, hier ist das AGB Update und dann hat die Verbraucherzentrale gesagt, äh,
Was steht denn hier? Ähm hier wird missbräuchlich das Vertragsverhältnis einfach einseitig geändert und da kommen wir in den Bereich, wo Volker wieder mehr Ahnung hat als ich. Das geht nicht so einfach, ne?
Ähm nee, das geht nicht so einfach, das ist schon mal die Frage, ob das aus äh ähm verbraucherschutzrechtlicher Sicht überhaupt so zulässig ist und das würde ich eigentlich eh nicht äh sehen, wie die Verbraucher, wie der Verbraucherschutz, äh, wie das Verbraucherzentrale ähm,
Das geht eigentlich nicht ohnehin. Also der Stil ist ja auch nicht besonders nett. Ähm also dass man sagt, so Kunde, du bist jetzt erstmal da mit drin, ne? Die Forlt ist, wir machen so einen Hotspot bei dir. Besser wär's ja genau andersrum, also besser optin als Optout. Ich glaube, das ist auch so für das,
Vertragsverhältnis oder des Kundenverhältnisses einfach deutlich besser, wenn man das so macht, ähm weil dann auch die Akzeptanz im Zweifel höher ist und ähm,
gesehen davon, ich meine, man kann das unterschiedlich beurteilen, klar ist es irgendwie schön, so im Prinzip mehr Möglichkeiten für Netzzugang zu haben.
Ob man das jetzt auf diese Art und Weise machen muss, weiß ich nicht, weil wie Tim schon sagte, wahrscheinlich wird den Kunden dadurch Bandbreite weggenommen und letztlich schafft sich Media dadurch so eine Art neues USP auf,
der eigenen Kunden, ne? Sie können immer sagen hier und wir haben hier tolle Hotspots und wir haben bei uns nicht Kunde ist, der darf die auch benutzen, der bezahlt uns aber dann auch nochmal extra dafür. Ähm, also das ist schon ziemlich merkwürdig, dass man da so als Erfüllungsgehilfe jetzt äh ähm davon Unitymedia unterwegs sein soll, wenn man
einfach nur ein Internetanschluss bei denen hat, finde ich eigentlich schade, dass man das so macht und eben natürlich auch gerade dann der Umstand, dass man sich da offensichtlich einloggen muss
oder in irgendeiner anderen Weise authentifizieren muss, denn ansonsten wäre ja nicht nachhaltbar, ob ich jetzt bei mir zu Hause auf meinem Router eben so einen Hotspot laufen habe, ne und damit ich dann auch auf die ganzen anderen Hotspots Zugriff habe. Also ähm,
das ist ein bisschen schwierig, da stellen sich bei mir, stellen sich mir auch so Fragen wie zum Beispiel, wie ist das
bei Familien oder wie ist es bei WGs zum Beispiel? Ähm da gibt's einen der formell der Anschlussinhaber ist, der auch äh den Anschluss bezahlt, aber es nutzen eben typischerweise in der WG oder in der Familie mehrere ähm wie stellt man jetzt sicher, dass die auch Zugriff haben, weil vielleicht
teilen die sich ja auch die Kosten und schmeißen alle zusammen, ne? Dann wär's ja irgendwie logisch, wenn die dann auch Zugriff hätten auf die Hotspots, die ansonsten so aufgemacht werden von Untymedia und ähm.
Ja, das, also dafür habe ich bisher noch so keine Lösung gehört, ne? Womit nimmt man dann einfach das Login des eigentlichen Ansp
Schlussinhabers, was ist, wenn dann ein WG-Mitbewohner, ein Familienmitglied irgendwas Strafbares dann macht, damit wird das dann zugerechnet? Und so weiter. Also eine ganze Menge Folgefragen tun sich da eigentlich auf,
die sich eigentlich weniger auftun würden, wenn man tatsächlich dafür gesorgt hätte, dass man eben flächendeckend offene.
Dann hätte man diese Probleme nicht so und wenn man eben das Ganze überhaupt in gemacht hätte, also das sind so so Schönheitsfehler, die doch so den Genuss dann arg trüben, würde ich sagen.
Hinzu kommt noch äh in den AGB steht dann drin, du darfst den äh Router nicht mehr ausschalten. Also nicht mehr nicht mehr langfristig ausschalten, also so,
weil du ja dann quasi deren Infrastruktur bei dir zu Hause betreibst, kannst die einfach ausmachen, ne? Die sind ja unsere Kunden drin.
Und du musst auch diesen Router tatsächlich benutzen. Also es ist eine Art faktischer Rutterzwang, der dadurch erzeugt wird.
Genau, ist nämlich Roter Zwang durch die Hintertür, das geht net, geht nur mit deren äh schrägen Rutern, ne
Und das wird auch äh also es wird auch wird auch sicherlich nochmal ganz interessant
wie sie da in ihren Routen dieses zweite Netz abgekapselt haben und wie sie gegenüber dem WLAN-Backen dann da eine Authentifizierung machen oder auch nicht. Ähm das wird nochmal ganz interessante äh Forschung, wenn man sich diese Dinger mal in Ruhe anschauen möchte.
Tja, findet also äh findet nicht so guten Anklang bei den äh Kunden und aber ich find's von der Technologie her
Trotzdem eigentlich keine so schlechte Idee, dumm ist halt, dass sie es wieder mit irgendeiner Form von komischen Einschränkungen und einem Geschäftsmodell verbinden wollen. Und da weiß ich echt irgendwie inzwischen gar nicht mehr.
Ob das also ob die nicht vielleicht auch einfach zu spät sind. So da das mit so einem Hotspot wirst du einfach keine Kohle mehr machen, oder? Das ist irgendwie vorbei.
Ja, es gibt hier jetzt bei der evangelischen Kirche demnächst auch. Für umsonst.
Wenn die die Kirche macht das für umsonst, ja? Gut, jetzt hat die Kirche jetzt auch nicht die die Preise für für Wein und Trockenbrot irgendwie in den Keller gedrückt, aber ähm ich weiß nicht, ob jetzt Hotspots so das große neue Ding sind.
Ich finde auch irgendwie generell eigentlich WLAN oder sehr eingeschränkt so als Bereitstellungsbasis für öffentliche veröffentlichen der Zugang geeignet. Also.
Also ich sage mal so, ne, solange wie in einer Welt leben, in der das vollkommen normal ist, dass äh mobilfunkzugänge Volumen beschränkt sind, ähm bin ich über jeden WLAN-Hotspot äh glücklich.
Das ist natürlich richtig. Ich meine ja auch nur technisch gesehen ist LTE definitiv,
Der bessere Ansatz, nur dass halt äh unser Oli Gupol auf der einen Seite, ja und eben auch solche konkreten Vertragsgestaltungen
solche sinnlosen Bandbreitenbeschränkungen, also die meisten sind sinnlos, also sehr viel mehr wäre. Müsste möglich sein, heutzutage schon, ja. Ähm dass das sozusagen derzeit natürlich die Spaßverderber sind.
Aber darauf dann sozusagen, ja dann,
Pumpen wir mal hier WLAN und am besten noch zwei Komma vier Gigahertz, wo sowieso nur drei Frequenzen wirklich äh benutzbar sind. Ja, jeder, der heutzutage seinen Laptop aufklappt, mal guckt, was für WLANs da sind, weiß, dass dass diese Technologie sich eigentlich selber kaputt spielt
weil einfach so viel Interferenz äh da ist. Ich meine, wer soll das nutzen, wenn ich in meiner Wohnung, im fünften Stock.
WLAN aufmache, ja.
Zumindest die Leute bei dir im Haus? Meinst du nicht.
Die Leute bei mir im Haus, die dann zufällig bei demselben Anbieter Kunde sind und deswegen auch so einen WLAN-Zugang haben, obwohl sie selber eigentlich einen DSL-Zugang haben, also das macht ja irgendwie alles.
Jetzt wir reden weiter noch über die Unity, Media Hotspots oder.
Ja, ja, ja, also grad dieses WLAN to go oder wie auch immer, sie es dann im Einzelnen nennen, also das ist jetzt dieser Telekom-Brain, den ich kenne, also dieses äh ja, das macht ja dann im eigenen Haus grade gar keinen Sinn, weil es ja dann eigentlich nur die Leute, die sowieso schon da Kunde sind, nutzen können.
Ich meinte eigentlich jetzt, es hörte sich ebenso an, als wenn du eher generell über Sinnhaftigkeit äh von WLAN äh dich auslässt und ähm da würde ich doch sagen, also da sehe ich jetzt erstmal das.
Technischer Ebene, das ist derzeit quasi noch der der Quick Fix ist für die Problematik, dass wir durch dieses oligolo
Uli Gopol im Mobilfunkbereich einfach dort noch nicht die die Preise und äh die Angebote an der Stelle haben, wo wir sie eigentlich haben müssten. Ja, okay
Da ist Freifunk eine Lösung, da ist
sind jetzt generell Cafés und so weiter eine Lösung, aber äh warum das überhaupt so ein großes Problem ist, dass man einfach mal einen bezahlbaren LTE-Vertrag
bekommt mit nennenswerten Bandbreiten, das erschließt sich mir halt auch nicht. Also auch das wird sich mittelfristig halt ändern,
WLAN als Technologie taugt halt nur sehr eingeschränkt. Die allerneusten.
Fortschritte im Bereich WLAN mit AC und Pipapo und Gigabit und so weiter sind sicherlich attraktiv nur wird natürlich gerade beim öffentlichen Zugang immer mit dem kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner gearbeitet, das heißt es ist immer noch,
zwei Komma vier Gigahertz mit entsprechenden Einschränkungen von vor Anne Dunemalz und das führt einfach nur dazu, dass alle WLAN's einfach noch schlechter benutzbar werden.
Gut, das können wir jetzt äh abschließen.
Genau.
Und komm wieder zurück auf ein ja auf was eigentlich, auf einen tollen auf unseren Skandal des letzten Jahres irgendwie.
Skandal des letzten Jahres und vor allem auf äh Felix Dunke, ja? Der Typ, ey, meine Güte. Ja, äh, nach dem Diesel-Gate-Vortrag äh beim äh zweiunddreißig C drei, wo er äh sicher ähm.
Mit dem Reverse Engineering dieser äh dieser äh Engine Control United eines Volkswagen auseinandergesetzt hat, äh hat er dann zusammen,
mit der deutschen Umwelthilfe jetzt mal irgendwie die Motorsteuerung von so einem Opel auseinandergenommen und die deutsche Umwelthilfe hatte schon vor mehreren Monaten gesagt, hier ähm
Abgasmessgerät an Opel Safira geknallt und da kommt irgendwie auch äh Gift raus wie nichts Gutes
Und ähm dann meinte Opel ihr Visuali, keine Ahnung, was äh wer wer ihr seid oder so, ne? Eins A Auto hier oder so. Und jetzt haben sie eine neue.
Ein neues Dossier äh veröffentlicht, äh wo sie äh vier Arten von Abgas äh,
Einrichtungen gefunden, Abgasabschalt oder nein, vier Arten von Abschalteinrichtungen dieser Reinigung. Es geht ja immer um das durch das,
Um das Einspritzen,
Von äh Harnstoff, äh der dann irgendwie die Stickoxid, den Stickoxidausstoß verringert. Und äh da haben sie festgestellt, na ja okay, diese Abgas äh Reinigung ähm funktioniert.
Ähm nur wenn.
Der äh die Laborprüftemperatur erreicht ist. Also äh zwischen zwanzig und dreißig Grad ist die Temperatur, die definierte Motortemperatur, wenn im Labor geprüft wird. Und wenn der Motor diese Temperatur hat, dann reinigt das Ding äh die,
reinigt das Ding das Abgas. Das heißt die haben tatsächlich eine Prüflauferkennung.
Während des bei ähm.
Bei VW ja andersrum war, die hatten eine Nicht-Prüflauferkennung. Also der hat während die die bei Opel quasi gesagt wird, ah okay, in so lange, dass da Laborbedingungen sein könnten.
Machen wir etwas,
VW war es so, wenn wir uns sicher sein können, dass es keine Laborbedingungen mehr sind, dann machen wir etwas, also ist eigentlich äh ein kleiner
Grober Unterschied nur äh kleiner Unterschied nur, aber der auf das Gleiche hinauskommt, aber so so tief hat, wurde das hier schon auseinandergenommen. Ähm,
irgendwie über hundertvierzig KMH machen sie's auch aus und ähm.
Haben irgendwie nur so ein super engen Bereich von am Ende irgendwie siebzig, achtzig Prozent eines normalen Betriebs für das Auto halt einfach,
die Dinger diese Abgasreinigung vollständig ausschaltet, ne? Und nur wenn's irgendwelche Testläufe sind und die erkannt werden, dann,
geht es an.
Und die haben jetzt also ihre Vorwürfe verschärft, haben mehrmonatige Analyse äh von Felix anfertigen lassen und ähm.
Opel sagt halt ja also hm die isolierten Erkenntnisse eines Hackers spiegeln nicht die komplexen Zusammenhänge eines modernen Abgasreinigungssystems wider sagt Opels,
zu dem Thema.
Insbeson.
Die ignorieren das jetzt.
Wirtschaftlichen Zusammenhänge spiegelt das vor allem nicht wieder. Wir haben doch keine andere Wahl. Wir kriegen das doch sonst nicht billig genug. Und guckt uns den Scheiß doch keiner an.
Und das ist aber wirklich so, das hauen sie so richtig laut raus, ne? Ist echt geil.
Das ist äh ja, ja.
Zusätzliche Stellungnahme, also das ist, das ist die, diese Stellungnahme habe ich gerade, das ist alles, ne?
Die ist vollständig verlesen mit isolierten Erkenntnisse eines Hackers spiegeln nicht die komplexen Zusammenhänge eines modernen Abgasreinigungssystems wieder. Ende das war's so. Das ist die Stellungnahme.
Doof, äh, wir gut.
Ja, so ungefähr, ne?
Ja. Na ja äh ich wundere mich ja bauen die nicht eigentlich letzten Endes alles irgendwie äh ist das nicht alles immer Bosch Technik die dort zum Einsatz kommt? Ja.
Das waren ja also der ich jetzt habe, jetzt ist es schon wieder einige Zeit her, der der dies im Diesel-Gate-Vortrag haben.
Fuhr das Fahrzeug ja immer in so einer Art Notfallbetrieb, ne? Also die der Teil der.
Von Volkswagen gebaut wurde, hat das äh das das Bauteil von Bosch Glauben gemacht, dass es irgendwie einen Notfallbetrieb gerade,
angeraten wie sei und dann hat das Fahrzeug eben diese ganze ähm,
Einspritzung ausgeschaltet. Ähm und da, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, war die Interpretation von Felix in dem Volkswagen äh Zusammenhang eben na ja.
Bosch hat denen das nicht gebaut? Die also das Bosch Bauteil wurde nicht manipuliert. Das hat.
Das sieht, sieht einfach das serienmäßig vor.
Genau und der und der VW-Teil hat den Boschteil eben gesagt, hier geh mal in den Ausnahmebereich.
Ja, also man muss halt auch sehen, Bosch Technik ist heutzutage im Prinzip,
so eine Art äh Motorbetriebssystem, da ist diese ganze Motorsteuerung drin, das ist eine sehr, sehr, sehr komplizierte Geschichte, also diese ähm wie heißt das Ding, Motor Control United MCU heißt das so.
ECO, Engine.
Engine Control, genau an die ECU, ja? Das da fließt, da ist halt viel, viel, viel Erfahrung.
Eingeflossen könnte man jetzt positiv sagen, man könnte auch sagen, das ist sozusagen ein ein äh,
ja seit Jahrzehnten weiterentwickelter Hack um das überhaupt alles im Griff zu kriegen, um überhaupt in irgendeiner Form noch mit irgendwelchen Abgasvorschriften klarzukommen,
Wenn man also solche Motor nicht permanent über tausende von Sensoren beobachtet und zu allen möglichen Konstellationen und Wetterumgebungs,
et cetera, Luftfeuchtigkeiten, Einspritzverhältnissen, Spr
Zusammenhängen et cetera, sonstigen Ölzuständen in diesem Wagen, wenn man das nicht alles die ganze Zeit zum KI mäßig miteinander äh verbindet und dann da versucht die Klaviatur richtig zu drücken
dann geht es halt komplett nach hinten los. Nur dass n.
Mir scheiß egal, dann sollen sie das so nicht verkaufen.
Ja gut, aber das ist halt das Ding, die die Lachsenvorschriften,
halt hier im Prinzip alle Hintertüren auch möglich gemacht und was wir ja im Kern feststellen, ich meine die können jetzt nicht noch so sehr dagegen wehren ob da alles mit rechten Dingen oder so weiter zugegangen ist. Die rechten Dinge sind an dieser Stelle halt einfach auch schon mal das Problem,
wenn man einfach mal hinten einen Stecker drauf macht mit dem Teil durch die Gegend fährt, wie jeder Dieselnutzer das sozusagen heute tausend äh und millionenfach äh in Deutschland einfach macht und dahinten kommen einfach.
Zehnfache hundertfache Überschreitung von äh nominellen Grenzwerten bei raus. Da muss man einfach sagen, diese Technologie,
ist am Ende und äh hat einfach abgeschafft zu werden und es ist halt einfach durch.
Also die deutsche Umwelthilfe macht auf jeden Fall jetzt einen Unterlassungsanspruch gegenüber der Adam Opel AG geltend ähm und äh
weist sie dann auch eben auf die Bewerbung dieses Fahrzeuges hin, wo sie dann irgendwie sagen, ja, wir haben den hier am äh in Schweden, wo es arschkalt ist, minus dreißig Grad haben wir den getestet und so und bei den Tests
Bei deren Tests kommt halt raus, dass dieses komplette Abgasreinigung,
ab siebzehn Grad plus ausgeschaltet wird oder so, ne? Äh weil's äh weil's Ding dann zu kalt ist. Ähm,
und äh das wird jetzt, die wollen halt das ganze Ding vor Gericht sehen. Und das wird dann nochmal schön, weil dann hätten wir ich glaube so einen der ersten oder nicht den ersten, aber doch einen der.
Ersten Industrie und Technikfälle, wo halt mal so ein Reverse-Engineer äh gute Chancen hat
als Zeuge vor Gericht zu sitzen, ne? Das ist dann nochmal ganz spannend, wenn du dir diese gesamte Idee des Digital Millennium Copyright Acts und dieser
Idee, wir schützen unsere Bauteile, unsere Software und so weiter, for Reverse Engineering. Am Ende hast du diese Leute eben als Zeugen vor Gericht, also das finde ich ähm sehr spannend und
dann ist dazu natürlich noch zu sagen, man klingt immer so, da wird immer so behandelt, als wäre das ein Kavaliersdelikt bei der Anzahl an Fahrzeugen.
Die die verkaufen, ne? Also Opel, Volkswagen in alle Welt. Und wenn dann da irgendwie so und so viel Milligramm pro äh Stunde ähm mehr ausgestoßen werden, dann sind das am Ende so und so viel Tonnen und das kannst du direkt übersetzen
Todesopfer, die du mehr hast pro Jahr und das sind äh da ähm mit niedrige bis mittlere fünfstellige Zahlen,
die damit wahrscheinlich oder die die äh unvermittelt dadurch im Zweifelsfall ihren frühzeitigen Tod äh gefunden haben,
dass es nicht nicht nur irgendwie so huch, wir haben einen Grenzwert nicht eingehalten, ne,
Insofern finde ich füllt mich das natürlich mit Stolz, dass äh dass da äh jemand mit dem technischen Sachverstand, der.
Ja, aber Linus, du weißt, die isolierten Erkenntnisse eines Hackers äh spiegelt nicht die komplexen Zusammenhänge eines modernen Abgasreinigungssystems wieder. Was ich mich allerdings frage, ist,
Spiegeln eilig die isolierten Erkenntnisse eines Unternehmensberaters die komplexen Zusammenhänge eines modernen Geheimdienstes wieder.
Ja, aber selbstverständlich denn. Ja, meine ich.
Meinst du? Ach so, na dann äh hm.
Also das ist wirklich eine eine wunderschöne Meldung. Du sitzt.
Seit Jahren sitzen die seit zwei Jahren, sitzen jetzt in dem NSL-Untersuchungsausschuss bald, ne?
Und diskutieren da über BND und Zusammenarbeit mit der NSA und Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und wir wollen gerne diese Lektoren einsehen. Und was war denn überhaupt los da bei euch? Und wer hat, wieso wusstet ihr alle von nichts und trotzdem ist alles irgendwie äh gelaufen, wenigstens Gutes? Und in einer solchen Zeit, wo sich dann
wie wir ja auch zuletzt gesehen haben im Opposition und.
Regierungsfraktion irgendwie zanken, ob sie den Untersuchungs, den Untersuchungsauftrag ausweiten auf bestimmte Selektoren und auf auf den BND. Ähm in einer solchen Situation wird auf einmal bekannt.
Die Unternehmensberatung Roland Berger soll den BND überprüfen. Die wurden beauftragt, die interne Kontrolle.
Der in der technischen Spionageabteilung des BND zu verbessern. Das ist der, das ist, ich meine, das ist der eine.
Das ist das eine, was wir wissen, ja, dass die interne Kontrolle beim BND nicht vernünftig funktioniert hat. So das ist das eine definitive Ergebnis des äh des des Erstens Untersuchungsausschusses, ja?
Bevor noch bevor es deinen Abschlussbericht gibt, ja, wird jetzt ausgerechnet Unternehmensberatung.
Damit beschäftigt. Der Auftrag sei auch öffentlich ausgeschrieben gewesen und Roland Berger hat eben den Zuschlag bekommen. Ähm.
Und die sollen jetzt ähm sich unsere Themen beschäftigen, dass eben die äh Abteilung technische Aufklärung mehr oder weniger ohne Kontrolle war, ähm dass da der,
irgendwelche Unterabteilungsleiter eigenmächtig Dinge entschieden haben ähm,
die sie nicht ihrem Vorgesetzten äh genannt haben, wie zum Beispiel das Entdecken der Tausende äh unzulässigen NSA-Selektoren, ne? Das ist irgendwie nicht nach oben gemeldet wurde, ähm dann diese gesamte Misere in Bad Aibling
Ähm und das soll sich jetzt Roland Berger anschauen.
Und soll die soll die Kontrolle von Anordnungen überprüfen. Das heißt, sie werden ein
werden im Herbst diesen dieses Jahres einen Vorschlag für ein engmaschigeres Kontrollsystem und neue Arbeitsprozesse ausarbeiten.
Das ist doch echt.
Das ist doch echt geil, ne? Da holt sie Unternehmensberater rein, die die dann sagen, ja pass auf, hier äh wir haben ja eure Prozesse gestreamt, so und hier habt ihr eine Meldepflicht und da das muss irgendwie äh weißt du?
Normalerweise holt man sich ja so einen Unternehmensberater äh rein, damit man eine Ausrede hat, irgendwie zwanzig Prozent. Das darf zu feuern.
Das werden die wahrscheinlich auch noch machen, ja.
Vielleicht ist das sozusagen jetzt der elegante Weg mit, na ja, also wir hätten euch ja schon gerne dabei, außen das nicht alles Beamte, die kriegen oder eh nicht gefeuert.
Ja gut, aber die können ja alle da, also da gibt's ja genug Aufgaben in so einem Staat, einfache Leute mit befassen kannst, ne. Das heißt ja nicht, dass die in der Position bleiben müssen.
Das ist da sozusagen Geheimdienstmitarbeiter zu. Was werden die dann konvertiert?
Goethe-Institut oder so, keine Ahnung. Irgendwas anderes, ne? Irgendwas mit Auslandsaufwä.
Oh, äh vielleicht Prüfingenieure im KFZ-Bundesamt.
Genau, irgendwie da gibt's ganz viele äh äh Tätigkeiten, ja, aber ich finde das echt geil, dass dass die eine Unternehmensberatung da reinholen, ne. Also die werden jetzt am Ende macht ihr dann deine Geheimdienstkontrolle, wird dir dann eben von ein paar Unternehmensberatern geschrieben
ohne Scheiße, ist vielleicht noch nicht mal so verkehrt, weil die werden sich die Sache wenigstens in Ruhe angucken. Blöd nur, dass die halt die ganze Zeit darauf getrimmt sind, Sachen auf Effizienz zu machen und da wird halt, da wird halt heißen, okay, mach weg,
Also, ne, hier äh dunkel durch, so.
Also mir ist auch zum Beispiel nicht klar, warum ausgerechnet eine Unternehmensberatung hier eine besondere Expertise beispielsweise in Sachen Grundrechte und ähnliches haben, sollte die ja durchaus vielleicht auch eine Rolle spielen äh bei solchen Fragen. Oder Rechtsstaatlichkeit und so.
Ja, es wirft doch alles Kosten auf.
Also die das eigentliche Problem also mal abgesehen eben sagen wir mal von der Praxis, die sich in diesen Behörden etabliert hat, ist ja vor allen Dingen die Rechtsgrundlage auf der sie arbeiten, ähm die ihnen selbst ja auch erlaubt, sich dann solche,
Dinge wie die Weltraumtheorie unser ausdenken zu können, womit sie sich letztlich ähm aus jeder rechtsstaatlichen Bindung verabschieden. Und
ähm da wäre es doch vielleicht sinnvoller, mal darüber zu reden und das passiert ja momentan auch äh wie man denn die Rechtsgrundlage, also BND-Gesetz und G zehn Gesetzt, wie man das eigentlich ähm,
effektiv umgestalten könnte
die die Vektoren zeigen da aber glaube ich in in eine ganz ungute Richtung wenn man sich jetzt zum Beispiel anschaut dass Herr Demazir der zwar jetzt nicht Chef des äh BND ist aber dann doch das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz eben hingeht und mit den Amerikanern also jetzt eine eine intensiveren Datenaustausch zum Beispiel vereinbart
und auch ansonsten es hier so aussieht
als wolle man dann bei der ähm bei der personellen Ausstattung solcher Behörden eben draufsatteln, bei der technischen Ausstattung solcher Behörden draufsatteln. Ähm,
Also da würde ich sagen, die Zeiger stehen da eigentlich eher in die in Richtung auf mehr Befugnisse, mehr Personal, mehr Ausstattung und ähm.
Dann wahrscheinlich auch mehr rechtliche Befugnisse. Also da wird's ziemlich interessant zu sehen, wenn diese rechtlichen Grundlagen,
reformiert werden, äh was denn da tatsächlich gemacht wird, nur ich habe so die Befürchtung,
dass es so ähnlich sein wird, wie es jetzt auch schon letztlich mit dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss war
interessiert 'ne Fachöffentlichkeit, aber die breitere Öffentlichkeit interessiert das nur sehr bedingt,
Dadurch ist eben der politische Druck auch nicht so besonders hoch. Ähm hier eher zurückhaltend äh in der Gestaltung der Gesetze zu sein.
Also vor allem ne und die werden dir kaum Gesetze schreiben, ne? Die werden halt in interne Anweisungen schreiben, ne?
Barcelona Berger jetzt ange
ja ja sicher, also da wird's wird's wohl eher um um die interne Strukturierung zu gehen, wobei da natürlich auch immer sich die Frage stellt, inwieweit das eben mit gesetzlichen Vorschriften zusammenpasst, nicht? Also die haben ja nicht einen unbegrenzten Gestaltungsrahmen da und können sagen
Was weiß ich, wir schaffen jetzt
mal irgendwelche internen Kontrollen oder so, zum Beispiel ab, sondern müssen sich eben auch an die an die verfahrensmäßigen Vorgaben äh durch Gesetze dann immerhin halten. Und da, wie gesagt, der Gesetzgeber ja schon auch die Möglichkeit nochmal ganz deutlich nachzusteuern, aber meine Befürchtung ist
dass das tatsächlich eher in die gegenteilige Richtung gehen wird. Also, dass es nicht so ist, dass der BND enger kontrolliert wird oder ähnliches, sondern,
wahrscheinlich sogar eher mehr Befugnisse bekommt.
Ich frage mich vor allem, was das, was der eigentlich für eine Cleans haben muss. Dieser Unternehmensberater.
Da werden mehrere kommen, das ist die das Unternehmen heißt so, das ist jetzt der.
Nein, schon klar, also.
Was was soll man mit was das sozusagen noch noch sehr viel komplexer macht. Also du brauchst sagen wir mal eine eine größere Teilmenge von Leuten, die einfach in ihrer Gruppe äh erstmal in der Lage sein muss ähm die Komplexität des BND,
der schon meinen Kopf sprengt, allein mit diesem neuen Gebäude, wenn ich da vorstehe, mir vorstelle, so das müsst ihr jetzt alles verstehen und das muss jetzt irgendwie neu gliedern. Wo man aber.
Nicht mal irgendwo reinlatschen kannst. Sagt er so, hallo, was macht ihr denn hier und so? Können wir euch feiern?
Nichts.
Sondern das ist halt alles irgendwie mit was weiß ich fünffach Sicherheitstür und tralala Zugriff dürfen wir ihnen nicht sagen und keine Ahnung und über solche Strukturen dürfen wir ihnen nichts verraten, also da widerspricht doch eigentlich der ganze gesamte
das gesamte Geheimhaltungsprinzip der der Struktur als solcher schon, die ja sozusagen schon teilweise nicht berichtet werden darf im äh Ausschuss.
Wird man, das immer ganz ganz effektiv lösen, so wie man das ja auch in anderen Geheimhaltungsbedürftigen Fällen ganz ganz effektiv löst, nämlich indem man einfach reinschreibt in die Verträge, dass die stillschweigend bewahren müssen.
Ja, muss NDA unterzeichnen.
Unfassbar effektiv so. Also.
Das heißt danach, wenn man sie dann fragt, na ja, warum, warum, warum schlagen sie denn diese Strukturänderung vor? Das kann ich ihnen jetzt leider nicht sagensgeheim.
Ja, aber das kennt man zum Beispiel so aus aus der Zusammenarbeit der Bundesregierung mit solchen Firmen wie äh CSC. Computerscience äh Cooperation, die ja so etwas salopp so von so Leuten wie John Götz zum Beispiel auch als äh die EDV-Abteilung der amerikanischen Geheimdienste ähm bezeichnet
Und ähm die haben auch 'ne deutsche Ausgründung, eine GmbH,
Und ähm die halt relativ viel sicherheitsrelevante Projekte für die Bundesregierung gemacht haben, zum Beispiel die kryptografisch gesicherte Kommunikation im Innenministerium
Linke hat mal eine kleine Anfrage dazu gestellt, wie ist denn jetzt eigentlich ist mit
Sicherheit der Informationen und so die im Zuge der Auftragserfüllung äh dann bei dieser Firma ähm anfallen, haben wir gesagt, ja also wir haben
die Verträge reingeschrieben, dass sie Stillschweigen darüber bewahren müssen. Das ist eine effektive Sicherung so von von solchen geheimen Informationen und ich nehme an, man wird das jetzt hier ganz genau so machen.
Ja, Sicherheit per Aklamation.
So, dann müssen wir jetzt mal langsam die nächsten Themen,
Den nächsten Themen widmen in Österreich äh liegt ein Ministerialentwurf für ein Gesetz vor, das Projaner,
ermöglichen soll zur Kommunikationsüberwachung und zwar haben sie da ähm die,
Eine ähnliche Trennung wie auch in Deutschland, also die agieren dann nach deutschen äh Vorbild so ein bisschen oder nach Deutscher,
nachdem Ablauf wie es in Deutschland auch war, nämlich die Trennung von einmal der der Durchsuchung, der Online-Durchsuchung und der äh Quellen Telekommunikationsüberwachung, sie nennen's einfach nur
Telekommunikations.
Überwachung hier. Ähm da gibt es konnte man bis glaube ich Ende letzter Woche oder so Stellungnahmen einreichen zu diesem Ministerialentwurf äh und das hat der.
Chaos-Computerclub Wien, der ja lieber dessen äh neu entstehen, wir ja eine Wiedergeburt wäre ja vor kurzem schon mal berichtet haben.
Als Thomas zu Gast war, äh zusammen mit äh dem äh Castcomputerclub.
Deutschland ähm eine Stellungnahme abgegeben, wo eben gesagt wird, hier, ne, diese Trennung der Quellen TKÜ und der Online-Durchsuchung ist eine rein sprachliche Trennung. Technisch ist es in Wirklichkeit,
das Gleiche, nämlich als,
Informationstechnisch als Chartprogramme zu klassifizierende Spionagewerkzeuge und es ist bei deren Anwendung unvermeidlich, dass auch in den intimsten Kernbereich äh der Zielpersonen eingegriffen,
wird oder werden kann. Und entsprechend äh spricht man sich da natürlich dann gegen äh den Einsatz von,
Österreich aus. Ich bin äh sehr gespannt. Österreich ist ja gerade sowieso für einige spannende Nachrichten gut. Äh es ist Montag.
Der zweiundzwanzigste fünfte, dass die Wahl des Wahlergebnis ist noch nicht die letzte Stimme ist noch nicht gezählt und die scheint ja bei dieser fünfzig fünfzig in Österreich reicht dann eh nochmal entscheidend zu sein,
Gerade hat Österreich noch mit anderen Problemen zu kämpfen, aber wir hoffen natürlich, dass diese Stellungnahme ähm bei den äh bei den Entscheidern äh gutes Gehör finden wird. Auch wenn.
Hoffen natürlich.
Ja, die Entwicklung in äh Österreich und wie auch eigentlich in die Entwicklung auch in Deutschland in gewisser Hinsicht äh kann man auch nochmal heranziehen, um zu betonen.
Überlegt euch gut, welche Mittel ihr euch so zulegt.
Potentiell missbraucht werden können. Allein das Vertrauen darauf, dass wir ja nur von Prigmatikern, die das alles nur gut meinen, äh, geleitet werden, äh
Das kann ich unbedingt so als gesichert angesehen werden und diese äh Chemiere von einem,
zum Beispiel rechten Umsturz ist vielleicht gar keine mehr
und damit müssen wir uns äh auch befassen und einfach klar sagen, wir müssen äh ein Recht erhalten, was äh eben wenig Missbrauchspotenzial hat und unsere Verfassung im Wesentlichen dazu da den
Bürger vor dem Staat zu schützen und nicht umgekehrt und das sind natürlich auch hier mit dem Staatstrojaner
alles solche kleinen Tendenzen, die mit ins große Spiel gehören.
Ja, man muss schon sagen, hier in Österreich äh ist es ja noch äh auf dem Stand eines Ministerialentwurfs, das heißt, man hätte jetzt noch im Rahmen des Gesetzgebungsverfahrens tatsächlich die Möglichkeit,
das Ganze entsprechend zu gestalten, grundrechtsfreundlich zu gestalten. Ähm, in der Bundesrepublik hatten wir kürzlich ähnliche Problematik, die beim Bundesverfassungsgericht aufgeschlagen ist mit dem äh BKA-Gesetz,
da ging's ja eigentlich auch genau um um solche Staatstrojaner,
und da muss man sagen war das Kind doch schon deutlich mehr in Brunnen gefallen, nicht? Also da haben wir zum einen eben dieses Gesetz, was äh traditionell sehr weitgehend ist ja auch schon eine Reaktion auf ein vorheriges Urteil war.
Ähm
Aber das ist äh tatsächlich gerade im Sicherheitsbereich in Deutschland offenbar ähm so der Modus Operandi, dass man ähm im Grunde erstmal so eine Art Maximalforderung stellt, ja? In in
Form, indem man halt sagt, so das ist auch total übertrieben, da sind dann keine Sicherungen drin und so weiter, also alles, was man so gerne hätte als Sicherheitswürde, dass man Kart-Planung eigentlich bekommt durch das Gesetz,
weiß man das Ding wird nach Karlsruhe gehen und dann lässt man sich das auf das höchstrichterlich grade eben noch zulässige Maß zurecht stutzen und das scheint so die Art zu sein, wie man eben hier die Grundrechte wahrt und verteidigt, nämlich indem man sie,
an die Grenze des höchstrichterlich erlaubten aushüllt. Und ähm das ist so eine gesetzgeberische Tendenz, die man eigentlich seit äh mindestens fünfzehn Jahren eigentlich hat, so im Sicherheitsbereich und die meines Erachtens wirklich hochgradig gefährlich ist,
und die eben auch das Verständnis eigentlich dieses Gemeinwesens hier äh doch finde ich ganz grundlegend ähm verändert und eigentlich,
von von den Füßen auf den Kopf stellt, muss man sagen. Ähm und leider,
Ist es auch so, dass jetzt gerade bei dem Trojaner des Bundesverfassungsgericht auch bei weitem nicht ähm so rigoros war, wie es hätte sein können, sondern so eine typische ja aber Entscheidung
gefällt hat, ne? Und gesagt hat, na ja, also einige Punkte in dem Gesetz, die gehen so eigentlich nicht.
Ähm und äh auch zum Beispiel eben dieser sogenannte Kernbereichsschutz, also wie kriegt man es hin, dass dieser intimste Kernbereich der privaten Lebensgestaltung vor den Augen des Staates äh verschlossen bleibt,
Und die Lösung ist dann immer na ja, also man kann ja eigentlich gar nicht anders Daten von der Platte erheben, anstatt dass man jetzt also als dass man jetzt einfach erstmal alles so in
Schleppnetzmanier sozusagen sich von der Pressplatte runterzieht und hinterher dann halt sortiert. Aber das muss dann eben eine unabhängige Stelle machen, die eben jetzt schon mal so kernbereichsrelevante Informationen ausfiltert und erst dann
darf sich das BKA daran gültig tun. Das heißt aber auch, diese diese Stelle, die das ausfiltert, ist in irgendeiner Form eine staatliche Stelle,
vielleicht ein Gericht oder so, aber jedenfalls äh ist es eine staatliche Stelle und deswegen ist dieser Kernbereich Schutz auch doch, muss man sagen,
arglöcherig mittlerweile und
Das ist eigentlich sehr schade, es galt wirklich mal, dass dieser Kernbereich unantastbar ist und dass der Staat grundsätzlich gar nicht eindringen darf, beispielsweise bei akustischer Wohnraumüberwachung, wenn's dann ähm
bisschen mehr zwischenmenschlich zuging, ne, dann musste man eigentlich abschalten, so eine Überwachung und durfte da also auch nicht zuhören, dass auch nicht aufzeichnen, erstmal auch nur um's dann hinterher wegzuschmeißen. Und ähm jetzt aber wenn's eben um die Erhebung
von solchen Daten per Online-Durchsuchung oder
eben durch den Staatsrojaner geht, da wird es aber schon so gemacht, man holt sich erstmal die Daten, dann sortiert man aus, was man eigentlich gar nicht haben dürfte und danach guckt man sich eben an, was übrig blei.
Das ist schon finde ich, also das entspricht nicht meinem Verständnis des Kernbereichsschutz, muss ich ganz deutlich sagen.
Ja, das war glaube ich auf der selben Seite.
Können wir ja noch kurz beim beim Kernbereichsschutz bleiben, wenn wir.
Dieser Podcast war unglaublich gute Laune merke ich gera.
So, ja? Das ist äh da sind wir ganz weit vorne hier.
Du wirst das an deinem.
In der Tat, ja.
Wie viele Jahre machst du das jetzt? Du bist jetzt auch schon drei, vier Jahre schon da.
Ja, also Fulda seit anderthalb.
Ah okay, warst du vorher gar nicht.
Vorher des Anfangs äh hatte die Digi gegessen, noch nicht so viel Geld vor der Stelle. Das äh musste erst, musste erst langsam angespart werden, ja.
Ein Fotojournalist ähm.
Der in äh Frankfurt die Blockupei Proteste fotografiert hat, ja? Ähm.
Hat eine Hausdurchsuchung bekommen vor ein paar Tagen. Ähm am Donnerstagmorgen ähm.
Der wohnt in Berlin Polizei, klopft an, macht Tür auf und nimmt ihn nimmt ihm die Computer und die äh Festplatten weg, die er so hat.
Haben dann die äh Wohnung noch durchsucht und da wollten ihnen denn
doch bitte die Passwörter herauszurücken, weil das verschlüsselte äh weil das verschlüsselte Datenträger sind, haben gesagt, äh wenn sie uns jetzt die Festplatten geben, oder wenn sie uns die äh das Passwort geben
dann können wir uns die Sachen kopieren, dann kriegen sie die Sachen wieder, aber ansonsten kann das natürlich echt so sechs bis zwölf Monate dauern, bis sie die Sachen wieder kriegen, ne. Da haben wir ja dann
Da haben wir dann viel Zeit in unsere Techniker sind nämlich gerade sehr beschäftigt.
Und ja dann haben sie halt diesen Journalisten, seine äh seine komplette Hardware weggenommen, Gel natürlich in der,
oder in der Annahme, dass sie darauf dann Fotos finden, äh die es ihnen ermöglichen, ähm Erkenntnisse für Ermittlungsverfahren zu gewinnen gegen ähm,
gegen Leute, die da in diesem Rahmen irgendwie straffällig geworden sind oder gegen die Verdacht besteht, dass sie straffähig geworden sind und ähm.
Finde ich schon äh auch mal wieder sehr.
Überraschend, dass die Leute das halt völlig in Ordnung finden, dass bei so einem äh,
Pressejournalisten schon zum zweiten Mal, der hatte äh zweitausenddreizehn schon mal äh dass die Wohnung durchsucht wurde, weil er bei irgendeiner Antikapitalismus,
Demonstration zweitausendzwölf dabei war, ja?
Der irgendwie Demonstrationen fotografiert. Das ist schon echt äh.
Nicht unbedingt besonders witzig und das ist auch nicht meine Idee von von Kernbereich, Schutz oder Presse äh Freiheit. Haben,
ihn auch nicht vorher gefragt, ob er ihnen die Bilder vielleicht freiwillig geben würde, weil sie ihn offenbar für einen Sympathisanten halten. Das heißt, seine die politische Gesinnung dieses Journalisten
wurde als oder die
die vermuten die vermutete politische Gesinnung des Journalisten wurde als Grund genommen äh seine Wohnung zu durchsuchen und seine Hardware zu beschlagnahmen. Das ist schon echt HardA.
Mhm. Hochgradig unangenehm, ja.
Die US.
Das ist das Thema wollte ich nur drin haben, weil das irgendwie in den USA wirklich die Leute enorm beschäftigt. Es läuft gerade ein.
Seit Jahren an anhängiges äh Gerichtsverfahren oder der Hauptverhandlung zwischen und Google
ist ja eigentlich bekannt für diese Datenbankdinger, die sie da machen und die haben vor einigen Jahren Sun Microsystems gekauft, Sun Microsystems, äh IT-Bude der ersten Stunde, würde ich jetzt mal so sagen, ne.
Auf jeden Fall.
Pionier und die haben äh sicherlich auch Gutes getan, aber eben auch die Programmiersprache Java.
So und ähm.
Es war nicht alles schlecht bei Sun M.
Es war nicht alles schlecht, was San Microsofts, die hatten teilweise ganz gut. Ja, also haben aber eben auch diese Programmiersprache, Jarbei in die Welt gesetzt. Und jetzt ähm.
Mehr noch und das ist in diesem Zusammenhang auch nicht ganz unwichtig. Es ist nicht nur eine Pomiersprache, sondern die AWA ist halt im Prinzip so eine eigene Art,
Betriebssystem, wenn man so will, eine eigene äh Umgebung
Traum äh und Network ist Computer, das waren so damals so die ähm.
Die Visionen, die das Hand dort in die Welt getragen hat und man kann ja auch sagen, das hat relativ früh viele Freunde gefunden, was ja dann eben auch zur Popularität dieser Sprache geführt hat. Also es war jetzt nicht nur die Sprache als solche, sondern es war
das gesamte Paket, also die äh Laufzeitumgebung, die Idee isoliert von gängigen Betriebssystemen unterschieden
laufen zu können et cetera. Und das ist ja durchaus auch viele Ideen, die bis heute betragen haben und in gewisser Hinsicht auch noch nach wie vor so ihre Nachfolger auch gefunden haben. Also.
Also du äh.
Es läuft halt nur nicht unbedingt immer auf Java hinaus, beziehungsweise nicht unbedingt immer auf das Jahr, aber wie sich das halt zan und später dann eben auch Orical vorgestellt hat, nachdem sie Sun gekauft haben.
Genau, denn,
Was dann geschah, also Javer gab es oder gibt es und die Java Virtual Maschinen gibt's eben auch so gut wie für jedes breit verbreitete, jede weiterverbreitete Plattform. Ähm und dann ist Google hingegangen und hat gesagt, hm.
Sprache habt ihr da.
Na, wir wollen hier äh Smartphones machen ähm wir haben nicht so viel Ahnung von
Betriebssystem wie wie Apple oder so, also lasst uns das mal das naheliegende machen. Wir knoten ein Linox um, das ist äh auch für mobil optimiert wird ähm und dann machen wir eine Javermaschine drauf. Ähm,
Die Dahlwick VM äh und dann haben wir weil Java so populär ist und an den Universitäten noch glaube ich relativ viel so äh in Jaba dann gesprochen wird. Ähm,
machen wir eine diese Umgebung und dann können wir diese ganzen Java-Programmierer schön auf unsere Plattform zuppeln. Dann können die da schön.
Ist alles irgendwie kompatibel, aber es handelt sich halt nicht um das Java von Orecle.
Und ist eben nicht kompatibel, das ist auch der Hauptstreitpunkt, nämlich.
Vielen Stellen ist es sehr wohl, also man kann
halt mit ja bei der Pohamiersprache, genauso arbeiten und auch an vielen anderen Stellen verhält sich das System halt identisch nicht durchgängig, weil es tut ja letztlich auch noch ein bisschen was anderes, aber äh im Prinzip war erstmal der Lockruf war,
Ja war im Wesentlichen so wie ihr es kennt, könnt ihr hier machen mit äh etwas anderer.
Mit ein paar Librarys mit ein bisschen und so weiter. Und äh jetzt benutzen sie, benutzen sie aber in diesem Android-Betriebssystem diverse äh Java, APIs,
wo Orice sagt, nee, nee, das sind aber unsere, die dürft ihr nicht benutzen. Und jetzt tanken die sich da und Google wirft ähm,
Orical mehr oder weniger durch die Blume vor. Ey, ihr habt doch Sun nur gekauft, um uns zu verklagen, ja? Ihr habt das doch, also ihr habt's,
ihr habt ja gesehen, ihr habt ja für mehrere hundert Millionen irgendwie Sun gekauft und dann irgendwie uns,
angezeigt. Das ist doch irgendwie so ein bisschen bisschen komisch.
Und Orical äh wirft eben Google vor, dass sie das Paradigma, das Unique Sales Point äh Paradigma Right Runs, äh Run Everywear, äh Run Ennyware, außer Kraft gesetzt haben, denn was du für,
Android entwickelt, das läuft eben nicht auf auf anderen Jaber vor M zwei, eben, da wirkt das schon äh ausreichend weg ist und genug ähm,
weitere Dinge eben definiert hat, um jetzt quasi eine eigene Umgebung zu sein. Und dann sagt Orical äh eben ja komm, ey, wir werfen hier irgendwie ein paar Millionen, äh paar Milliarden äh Dollar für Forschung und Entwicklung jedes Jahr raus. Äh damit schaffen wir Dinge, das ist Arbeit und ihr,
erntet jetzt eben diese Früchte.
Wir werden sehen, wie da geurteilt wird. Ähm das ist halt auch wieder so eine Geschichte mit mit geistigem Eigentum und so und und was weiß ich, was welche diese diese APIs, die da genutzt werden, die kenne ich auch nicht, aber es ist sehr.
Ein Thema, was eben äh in den die USA gerade sehr beschäftigt, weil's eben um dieses geistige Eigentum
von von Software, Software, Patenten, Softwareideen und so weiter geht. Und das ist natürlich schon ganz Verfahren, wo es jetzt eben um,
Millionen oder Milliarden geht. Ähm.
Google wird aber sowieso natürlich an jeder Ecke für alles mögliche verklagt und wenn du irgendwie den Eindruck hast, dass Gori irgendwie deine rechte verletzt bist, natürlich gut beraten. Zumindest zu versuchen, dein dein Stück von den Kuchen,
daraus zu holen und das tut jetzt. Ich hab so ein bisschen den Eindruck, die Amerikaner den ich in der Hinsicht folge.
Ähm haben eher so den Eindruck, dass äh Google hier im Recht sei und nicht Orikal.
Weil es ist auch eine generelle Frage, würde mich auch nochmal interessieren, Volker, ob du da so ein bisschen Einblick hast, weil dieses Apis,
Copyright oder andere Rechtsvorlagen schützbar zu machen,
Im Sinne von, das ist ja hier geistiges Eigentum, ja. Wir haben uns ja die Mühe gemacht und uns was ausgedacht und jetzt benutzt ihr das einfach so ihr Bösen. Man muss äh vielleicht auch nochmal für die, die das so von der,
pur Mierseite her nicht so durchdrungen haben, weil das einfach nicht ihr Feld ist. Äh vielleicht nochmal kurz beschreiben, also eine API.
Also eine Application Programm Interface ist erstmal ja nicht Code. Das ist eigentlich nichts anderes als eine Vorschrift wie Code sich verhält.
Und in dem Moment, wo Google hergeht und sagt,
Wir haben hier mal Code geschrieben und der verhält sich genauso wie ihr das mit eurem Code auch macht. Wir haben wir haben einfach dasselbe Verhalten modelliert, aber nicht euren Code genommen,
Halte ich persönlich für eine absolut nachvollziehbaren Schritt und äh,
halte wiederum das Design des Apis an der Stelle nicht für,
ausreichend schutzwürdig, um's mal zurückhaltend zu formulieren, weil das ja sozusagen nur eine Idee formuliert, wie sich etwas äh verhält. Selbstverständlich.
Fließt in das Design eines solchen APIs eine Menge Energie, Menpower et cetera äh rein, nur dass es meistens eher ein Abfallprodukt einer konkreten Programmierleistung ist,
Weil man kann natürlich auch APIs aufstellen und sagen hier, wir haben zwar noch keinen Code geschrieben, der das irgendwie.
Tatsächlich Macht, ja, aber wir definieren das jetzt mal so. Das ist eigentlich in der Softwarewelt sehr
unerfolgreiche Dinge, das sind meistens so die Ergebnisse von irgendwelchen Komitees
Die sagen na ja, so müsste das jetzt irgendwie sein und dann passiert das aber nicht. Da gibt's ja schon so früher, also Rosi Modell und so weiter, das
waren alles irgendwie Sukimehren, die da nie so richtig äh lebendig geworden sind oder auch ein sehr schönes Beispiel
der lange postulierte Nachfolger von HTML, das X HTML, ja, was auch nie einer so richtig machen wollte, weil die Leute einfach gesehen haben, in dem Moment, wo man das konkret umsetzt, läuft man einfach gegen so viele Wände, das ist einfach nicht praktikabel
und ähm.
Hat dem Ellis dann auch ein schönes Beispiel, weil man dann eben gesagt hat, okay, den Fortschritt definieren wir jetzt nur noch durch Running Code, das heißt, wir erheben alle nur noch Sachen zum Standard, die auch mindestens irgendwie ein, zwei Mal äh erfolgreich implementiert worden sind, weil sonst hat sich das äh quasi nicht bewiesen.
Sprich diese ganzen APIs
jetzt meint, sie hätten da irgendwelche Schöpfertypen, die in so einem großen Thron, auf so einem großen Thron sitzen und den ganzen Tag, die sich einfach so ausdenken und dann sind die so in der Welt und dann,
Programmierer und sagen oh ja heiliger Api jetzt implementiere ich dich und alles wird gut. Das ist ja eigentlich hat mit der Realität
nur sehr eingeschränkt was mitzutun, sondern da wird einfach Code geschrieben, dieser Api ändert sich im Laufe äh der Softwareerstellung am laufenden Meter. Trotz alledem haben wir jetzt eben diese Unternehmen, die eben versuchen, darüber eine
Macht auszuüben und anderen sozusagen daran zu hindern, kompatible Software zu bringen, was ja auch auf Open Source Software dann Auswirkungen hätte, ja, was es mit Dateiformaten, ja? Sind das im Prinzip dann auch schon APIs?
Hatten wir sicherlich auch schon ein paar Mal. Nimmst du das einen Euro? Ist das bei euch schon mal ein Thema gewesen, eigentlich bei der digitalen Gesellsch.
Das also meines Wissens eigentlich nicht, weil das jetzt auch ähm so unmittelbar dann eher was ist, was sich sagen wir mal zwischen Unternehmen abspielt und unser Spielfeld ja dann eher Grundrecht und Verbraucherschutz sind und ähm diese Fragen.
Die also so wettbewerbsrechtlicher Natur ja eigentlich eher sind, ähm weniger eine Rolle spielen. Aber ähm ich glaube, du hast es eigentlich schon ganz gut ähm umrissen mit dem, was du gerade eben gesagt hast mit deiner Beschreibung,
Denn letztlich die Schöpfungshöhe wird dann entscheidend dafür sein, ob irgendwas tatsächlich dann einem irgendwie gearteten Schutz des geistigen Eigentums unterliegt oder nicht und ähm.
Davon letztlich wird es abhängen und ich erfinde ja schon, dass dass es ein Argument ist, dass wenn die Entwicklung.
Eine API tatsächlich so viel Aufwand kostet wie Orgal behauptet,
dann ist es ja durchaus ein signifikanter Faktor, also dann das zeigt ja dann auch, dass es offenbar wirtschaftliche Interessen ganz stark an der Vermarktung in dieser Art hier und so gibt und die möchten, denke ich mal, dann selber ähm entsprechend wahrnehmen, diese Möglichkeiten und wollen eben nicht das andere diese
durchkreuzen, also das finde ich durchaus nachvollziehbar, ähm, ob jetzt diese Behauptungen, die da in dem Zusammenhang gemacht werden, so alle zutreffend sind und das wird sich dann ja dann
zeigen, wenn wenn so ein Verfahren tatsächlich durchgeführt wird und dem man dann versucht, dieser Argumentation näher auf den Grund zu gehen, aber,
Ansonsten weiß ich nicht, habe ich da eigentlich keine dezidierte Meinung jetzt zum Thema.
Na, ich meine, ich sehe es halt vor allem auch als Probleme. Ich meine, wenn sie zwischen so zwei Unternehmen abspielt, wie jetzt mit Orecy und Google, ist ein bisschen schwierig, da.
So seine Vorlieben zu finden und und da hängt das vielleicht viel damit zu tun wie man jetzt irgendwie cooler oder uncooler findet. Aber wenn ich mir halt jetzt überlege dasselbe Denissens würde jetzt laufen zwischen äh
Orecal und Open Source, ja? Wobei in dem Zusammenhang muss man sagen,
es dann Lizenzvereinbarung von Orecal, zum Beispiel mit Apache, die eben auch äh
Jawa, Cotia, als Open Source rausbringen und da selber Systeme entwickeln. Äh darüber kann ich jetzt nicht sehr viel sagen, wie die im einzelnen geregelt sind, aber auch an der Stelle ist schon schon so merkwürdige Lizenzvereinbarungen äh da
die ich jetzt grundsätzlich erstmal in Frage stellen würde, ob die überhaupt erforderlich sein sollten. Ich denke, das ist ähm auch nachvollziehbar ist, dass man sagt.
Da gibt es etwas, was sich irgendwie verhält, nichts anderes ist ja eine API, ja? Das ist ein Verhalten, was abstrakt beschrieben wird. Im Übrigen, sowie die,
auch definiert sind, ist auch noch nicht unbedingt garantiert, dass sich der Code dahinter auch tatsächlich immer so verhält.
Fehlerabweichungen nicht dokumentierte Bereiche et cetera. Aber wenn man jetzt sagt, grundsätzlich ist das Nachahmen einer Funktionalität nicht erlaubt,
und ich muss das, was eigentlich dort schon perfekt beschrieben ist und was auch in gewisser Hinsicht schon vielleicht ein Monopol ist,
das darf dann nicht nachgebildet werden und es dürfen keine Alternativen dazu geschaffen werden, obwohl im Prinzip der Hauptaufwand wirklich das Kurden ist. Das halte ich doch für,
stark überdenkenswürdig und ist halt auch die Frage, ob das nicht dann in irgendeiner Form auch Grundrechte äh tangiert, ob.
Also ich meine, das gibt's ja einen anderen
Ja, es gibt ja in anderen Bereichen ähm auch, also so ein so ein Gebrauchsmusterschutz oder so, das da geht's ja auch oft einfach nur darum, wie etwas genau funktioniert, was weiß ich, das Wischen über den Bildschirm oder sowas, ja? Und das kann man sich auch äh schützen lassen, ganz egal durch welche
Programmierung, die dahinter steht, man das es konkret erreicht hat, sondern da geht's tatsächlich um die Funktionalität
Insofern, also das finde ich als keineswegs ab, wiege ich auch so eine Funktionalität irgendwo unter den Schutz des geistigen Eigentums zu subsumieren
das das kann schon so sein, aber wie gesagt, es kommt dann eben immer konkret darauf an, wie genau ist das eigentlich abgrenzbar, wie viel Originalität in Anführungsstrichen steckt da drin und ähm
Genau, also deswegen denkbar ist er schon, ich kann aber, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, zu dem Fall jetzt auch da bin ich zu wenig mit den Einzelheiten vertraut, um da eigentlich sinnvoll was zu sagen zu können.
Dann machen wir weiter. Noch jetzt kommen wir wirklich zurzeit kurzer Anmeldung. Ähm IT-Sicherheit jetzt auch bald per EU-Richtlinie.
Äh es gibt jetzt eine äh einen Entwurf für eine für eine für eine IT-Sicherheitsrichtlinie auf EU-Ebene. Der muss jetzt noch vorm Parlament in der zweiten Lesung gebilligt werden, da geht man aber davon aus, dass das
locker durchgeht und dann diese Richtlinie im August in Kraft treten wird.
Dann wiederum haben die EU-Länder zwei Jahre Zeit, sie in nationales Recht umzusetzen.
Und da geht es dann äh in dieser Richtlinie primär um äh Meldeauflagen für Betreiber essentieller Dienste.
Also kritischer Infrastrukturen wie äh Energie, Wasserversorgung, Transportfinanzwesen und so weiter. Ähm.
Und auch irgendwie größere Online-Plattformen und Internetdienste selber,
und dann wird es eben dort auch Meldepflicht bei Cyberangriffen geben. Jetzt auch auf jetzt auch EU-weit,
Ähm ich sah erwähnt erst nur, weil ja das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz in Deutschland vor gar nicht allzu langer Zeit beschlossen wurde, wann war das irgendwann letztes Jahr,
muss letztes Jahr gewesen sein, dass es beschlossen wurde. Da hatte ich ja damals auch ein bisschen eine Stellungnahme zu verfasst und,
eine gute Nachricht, die man mal so nebenbei reinschieben kann. Die Niederlande haben einfach mal Zerorating verboten.
Also Zero Rating haben wir hier auch schon öfter behandelt. Jene Verletzung der Netzneutralität, bei der du bestimmte Anbieter
von dem von der Anrechnung
auf das Datenvolumen befreist, so wie es äh die deutsche Telekom mit Spotify macht, wenn man es über sie bucht und ähm.
Ähm so wie es Facebook mit seinem Internet dot org äh oder bei Freebasics heißt es ja jetzt versucht mit äh Mobilfunk Providern zu machen, das eben äh man einen kostenlosen
Facebook-Zugang bekommt und wenn man dann auf die
von Facebook weglinks klickt eben das Internet bezahlen muss oder eben auch einfach,
aufgefordert wird, äh ein Internet äh Anschluss abzu
schließen. Äh einen Internetvertrag, weil du das eben einfach hast. Da kannst du dich auch gar nicht gegen wehren. Kaufst 'ne Telefonie-Simkarte, wenn du dann da irgendwie,
anfängst darauf, Daten zu sprechen, dann gibt's eben Facebook für für Oma. Genau das haben die Niederlande verboten.
Während wir ja äh die wie Thomas in der Sendung ausführlich erklärt hat, eigentlich gerade noch äh in der Bereg,
darüber diskutieren, wie denn die Richtlinie, die hier keine konkreten Vorgaben macht umzusetzen,
sei, denn da dieser EU-Beschluss, der lässt eine konkrete Regelung zu Zero-Ratings offen und die Niederlande sind, haben jetzt halt, wir sind jetzt hingegangen, haben gesagt, nee, gehen wir nicht, machen wir nicht.
Ja, beim Zero Rating ist ja eigentlich noch ein weiterer Punkt relativ relevant, äh der jetzt gerade in keiner der Stellung nicht vorkam, nämlich ähm.
Datenverkehr von und zu einem bestimmten Dienst wird nicht auf das Datenvolumen angerechnet und wenn das Datenvolumen aber dann durch die Nutzung der anderen Dienste erschöpft ist und die dann gedrosselt werden, kann man aber den gezerote,
immer noch voll umfänglich nutzen und genau das ist ja eigentlich dann der wesentliche Marktvorteil, den sich ein solcher Zero-Rating-Dienst dann eben erkaufen kann gegenüber der Konkurrenz, ne.
Der funktioniert einfach grundsätzlich und immer und Datenvolumen streichst du dann eben irgendwann komplett.
Genau und das ist ja ein Dienst, den dann also in der Regel sowohl die Kunden
bezahlen, wie jetzt bei diesem Spotify-Angebot der Telekom, aber eben natürlich auch der Sirurating Dienst selber, der zahlt natürlich an dem Provider auch dafür
gerade große Dienste können sich das eben leisten und kleinere Dienste können sich das in der Regel nicht leisten und damit können sich eben bereits etablierte Dienste, einen Wettbewerbsvorteil erkaufen, was im Ergebnis dazu führt, dass die großen Größe
werden und die Kleinen eben klein gehalten werden und damit
genau das, was man den Kunden ja immer verspricht, nämlich, dass sie dadurch ein Meer bekommen, irgendwie ein ein Plus, eine bessere Auswahl haben, ja, genau sagen können, das ist der Dienst, den ich habe,
Auf lange Sicht ist das eben genau nicht der Fall, auf lange Sicht nimmt nämlich die die Auswahl dadurch ab,
und wir haben eben eine Konzentrierung auf einige wenige große Anbieter und haben eben immer weniger Alternativen und so die Innovationskraft des Internets, die ja eigentlich das ist, was es zu dem gemacht hat, was es heute ist, ähm
die wird dadurch erheblich geschwächt und eingeschränkt und das ist eigentlich der Grund, warum man was gegen Zero Rating haben kann,
warum man auch wohl in den Niederlanden sich jetzt zu dem gesetzlichen Verbot äh durchgerungen hat und das ist in der Tat, finde ich, juristisch vielleicht nochmal ganz interessant, ähm im Verhältnis eben zu der ähm Verordnung, ist keine Richtlinie, die wir da haben auf europäischer Ebene, sondern eine eine Verordnung.
Gut, dass du es nochmal sagst. Erkläre nochmal ganz kurz den Unterschied, weil ich diese Begriffe echt öfter mal.
Richtlinie ist nur eine Vorgabe äh die dann umgesetzt werden muss in äh nationales Gesetz und die Verordnung.
Ist quasi schon das EU.
Das die Verordnung ist ein EU-weit unmittelbar gültiges Gesetz. Die Richtlinie ist ein Gesetzgebungsauftrag an die Mitgliedsstaaten genau,
Und ähm! Das heißt also eigentlich gilt die Verordnung unmittelbar und die ist auch jetzt schon in Kraft
seit April ist sie in Kraft tatsächlich, ja? Ähm das war auch der Punkt, als dann die Telekom hingegangen ist und ihr Spotify-Angebot leicht verändert hat,
OK es ist immer noch so, wir rechnen den Datenverkehr von uns zu Spotify nicht auf, äh, das Datenvolumen an, aber wenn das Datenvolumen erschöpft ist, wird Spotify genauso gedrosselt wie alle anderen auch.
Und haben dann gleichzeitig mit dem Finger auf diese EU-Verordnung gezeigt und gesagt, das liegt nämlich an der Netzneutralität, also was natürlich ein interessanter
Lobbying-Move sozusagen ist, den die da gemacht haben, weil sie natürlich versucht haben, die Leute, die jetzt schon Spotify nutzen, dadurch so ein bisschen auf die Beine zu bringen ähm und die Netzneutralität äh da in schlechtes Licht zu rück,
Tatsächlich ist es aber so, wie du gerade eben schon gesagt hast, diese Verordnung sagt eigentlich gar nicht,
genau irgendwas. Sie sagt weder pro noch Contra Zero Rating irgendwas. Es ist ziemlich offen, weil sie das gibt viele Stellen, an denen diese Verordnung unglaublich wage ist, ne? Und gar nicht klar ist, was,
Und das soll eben jetzt überhaupt erstmal in einem Konsultationsprozess durch die Berik, also diese Dachorganisation der EU-Telekom-Regulierer.
Herausgefunden werden und erst, wenn das tatsächlich abgeschlossen ist und die Leitlinien der Bärik erlassen sind, dann weiß man, wie denn jetzt praktisch diese Verordnung Anwendung findet und ob sie tatsächlich das Zero-Rating verbietet äh
oder nicht und die Niederlande haben jetzt eigentlich so einen Vorstoß gemacht, sind schon mal so ein bisschen vorgeprescht und haben halt gezeigt, äh wir sind der Meinung
gehört verboten,
Das ist insofern ein bisschen problematisch, als das eigentlich ein Verbot der Doppelregulierung gilt, das heißt in dem Augenblick, in dem eine fragerechtlich geregelt ist, auf EU-Ebene darf sie eigentlich nicht nochmal auf nationaler Ebene geregelt werden,
Das heißt also wenn am Ende die zu dem Ergebnis kommt,
diese Verordnung regelt tatsächlich was zu Zero Rating, dann müssten wahrscheinlich die Niederlande ihr Gesetz auch wieder aufheben.
Aber bis dahin sozusagen haben sie jetzt erstmal Fakten geschaffen und sind jetzt eben einfach erstmal vorgeprescht und haben gezeigt, ähm, diese Praxis, die soll's hier eigentlich überhaupt gar nicht geben.
Das ist ja eigentlich erstmal ganz schön, wenn man wie gesagt, man.
Wird, es könnte den also wieder einkassiert werden.
Ja, ja, genau, also wenn wenn es so sein sollte, dass das Ergebnis nachher der der Leitlinien der Bereg ist, die EU-Verordnung regelt etwas zu Zerorating, ne? Da gibt's verschiedene Passagen, je nachdem, wie man die auslegt, kommt man zu dem Ergebnis,
man kann Regelungen über Sero Rating da reinlesen oder nicht.
Und je nachdem eben jetzt, zu welchem Ergebnis die Dachorganisation der Telekom-Regulierer kommt, ähm könnte das eben bedeuten, dass diese niederländische Regelung eigentlich gegen dieses Verbot der Doppelregulierung verstößt und deswegen wieder aufgehoben werden müsste.
Okay.
Ja, also ist so ein politisches Ausrufezeichen, das finde ich eigentlich ganz interessant dadran, dass man es in dieser Form mal gemacht hat ähm und was eben deutlich einfach zeigt, wie da das Parlament mehrheitlich positioniert ist und das finde ich eigentlich gar nicht schlech.
Könnte auch eine Auswirkung auf die Verhandlung der Berek haben oder die eigentlich von solchen Prozessen eher entkoppelt.
Ja doch glaube ich schon, denn ähm die Berek ähm macht,
also demnächst noch eine öffentliche Konsultation, an der kann sich auch jeder beteiligen. Übrigens auch über ein Tool, was äh die digitale Gesellschaft zusammen mit unserer Dachorganisation Edri gebaut hat. Save the Internet dot you heißt das und es gibt,
die Möglichkeit sich sehr einfach und niedrigschwellig an diesem Konsultationsverfahren zu beteiligen und wenn man mal fünf bis zehn Minuten übrig hat,
in die Bresche springen möchte für Netzneutralität, dann sollte man das auf jeden Fall machen. Da findet man auch eine Hilfestellung. Ähm, weil manche von den Fragen,
Überfordern den ein oder anderen vielleicht zunächst, aber da gibt's dann Erklärungen dazu und Hilfestellung, ähm wie man die sinnvoll beantworten kann. Und ähm.
Dass tatsächlich solche Konsultationen und die Beteiligung da dran was bringen könne, das hat man eigentlich zweitausendvierzehn in den USA gesehen, al
die dortige FCC, das ist die dortige Regulierungsbehörde für Telekom eben auch eine solche Konsultation gemacht hat zu Netzneutralitätsfragen und da im Ergebnis fast vier Millionen Kommentare eingegangen sind,
das Ganze schließlich gemündet ist in der eher netzneutralitätsfreundliche und verbraucher
freundliche Regulierung, was man ursprünglich da gar nicht für möglich gehalten hätte. Also insofern, das kann tatsächlich was bringen und es ist immer gut, da seine Stimme
in in den Ring zu werfen und sich tatsächlich an sowas zu beteiligen. Und da denke ich eben, wenn es in den Niederlanden jetzt schon so ist, dass sie da auch so ein Gesetz haben
darüber berichtet wird, Leute das wahrnehmen, dann vielleicht auch er sich mal mit dieser Frage beschäftigen, was ist Sirurating und was ist eigentlich davon zu halten und warum haben die das jetzt eigentlich verboten? Kann das durchaus dazu führen, dass eben aus der Bevölkerung auch mehr Beteiligung an so einer Konsultation ähm daraus resultiert,
Was eben sehr schönes Ergebnis wäre. Also insofern politisch finde ich ein gutes Signal.
Ein weiteres politisches, gutes Signal wünschen wir uns für die äh Berufung, die Chelsea Manning jetzt eingelegt hat,
gegen ihre Verurteilung drei Jahre hat es gedauert diese Berufung zu formulieren.
Es wird letztendlich argumentiert, dass hier nun mal wirklich ähm ein.
Drakonisches Strafmaß von fünfunddreißig Jahren, äh da erhalten hat und äh es irgendwie keinen nennenswerten,
Hinweise gibt, dass durch die Veröffentlichung der Kabels, um die es dabei ja geht ähm ein so ein ausreichend,
verhältnismäßiger Schaden äh für die USA entstanden sei der, der diese Strafe äh in irgendeiner Form rechtfertigt. Da können wir nur viel Erfolg bei wünschen.
Ja und ansonsten haben wir noch paar Danksagungen aussprechen.
Ich kann Danksagungen aussprechen, ja an äh Nora, Esther, Costia und Heiko Christopher und.
Ein oder zwei unbekannte Personen, denn äh Amazon hat mir irgendwie Pakete geschickt, wo
keine Bekennerschreiben bei,
und äh jetzt weiß ich nicht, ich habe dann erstmal noch kurz geschaut, ob das vielleicht von meinem Konto abgebucht wurde, ob ich das schon bezahlt habe oder so. Aber nein
und da würde ich mich freuen, wenn die beiden Personen, die jetzt nicht genannt wurden, sich vielleicht irgendwann nochmal kurz bei mir melden würden über.
Das Kontaktformular oder so, was man im Internet findet, irgendwie. Ja, ich will mich da gerne nochmal bedanken.
Ich kann auch danke sagen und zwar an Volker, der hier das erste Mal da war und das äh war super.
Ja, vielen Dank für die Einladung. Hat mich sehr gefreut.
Sicherlich nicht das letzte Mal.
Genau, jetzt haben wir dich auf der Liste. Auf dem Kika haben wir dich jetzt. Ja.
Wie siehst du denn insgesamt in die äh in die Welt gerade? Ähm äh weil.
Netzpolitisch meinst du.
Die Lage der Nation.
Ja ist ehrlich gesagt hm ich weiß nicht ähm,
also leider nicht allzu hoffnungsvoll, muss ich sagen. Die Erfahrung, die wir jetzt mit der großen Koalition gemacht haben, waren doch eher sehr ernüchternd, was äh Netzpolitik angeht. Ich erinnere nun mal daran, wie die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gegen alle Proteste,
durch den Bundestag geprügelt wurde. Ähm, ich finde jetzt auch, wie es bei der WLAN-Störerhaftung läuft, gerade das Gesetzgebungsverfahren,
hätte wirklich schöner sein können und ähm,
insgesamt auch die Entwicklung bei Überwachung und Geheimdiensten finde ich geht nicht in eine besonders gute Richtung.
Ähm auf europäischer Ebene ist es jetzt sagen wir mal etwas besser ähm
da ist es immerhin so, dass man so das allerschlimmste verhindern konnte. Also sprich Datenschutzgrundverordnung zum Beispiel oder eben jetzt auch bei der Verordnung zur Netzneutralität, alles nicht ideal, wie man sich's wünschen würde, aber
jedenfalls auch nicht so schlimm, dass man sagen müsste, es ist jetzt der der absolute Untergang hier, der uns bevorsteht oder sowas. Ähm.
Das nächste, was da so aufm Tape ist, ist die Urheberrechtsreform und da darf man wirklich gespannt sein, dass es ein wahnsinnig dickes Brett unglaublich viele unterschiedliche Fragen, die da eine Rolle spielen.
Und ähm das glaube ich wird eine ziemlich spannende Auseinandersetzung ähm in Deutschland glaube ich werden wir jetzt äh,
So ungefähr anderthalb Jahre mehr oder minder Stillstand haben, da wird nicht viel passieren, weil
nicht mehr lang hin bis zur Sommerpause und nach der Sommerpause ist dann Wahlkampf und da werden die großen Dinge also zum Beispiel Umsetzung der Datenschutzgrundverordnung glaub ich nicht mehr wirklich angepackt vor der nächsten Wahl,
da wird man einzelne kleine Fragen vielleicht regeln, aber die wesentlichen Fragen glaube ich eigentlich eher nicht. Und das ist sehr schade, weil sind bewegte Zeiten und gerade jetzt,
es vielleicht wichtig auch mal gestalten voranzugehen, das sehe ich aber leider nicht, dass es mit dieser Bundesregierung tatsächlich passiert im Netzpolitischen Bereich. Also
Wie gesagt, ziemlich finster auf nationaler Ebene etwas besser auf europäischer Ebene, aber es also umso wichtiger ist es, glaube ich, dass die Zivilgesellschaft sich da weiter engagiert,
tatsächlich versucht eine Änderung herbeizuführen und immer wieder über diese Themen redet, immer wieder versucht eine Öffentlichkeit dafür zu schaffen und immer wieder Leute dazu aufruft, eben der Politik auch zu sagen, was man eigentlich will und eben deutlich zu machen
dass Netzpolitik in andere Richtung gehen muss als dass man die Leute die im Netz unterwegs sind so degradiert
auf auf die zwei Betrachtungsweisen Wirtschaftsfaktor und Sicherheitsrisiko und das scheint so momentan eigentlich das zu sein, äh wo es wo es hingeht und deswegen glaube ich ist es extrem wichtig.
Ist gerade aus der Zivilgesellschaft eben da Protest gegen so eine Haltung kommt und auch konkrete Vorschläge, wie man's besser machen könnte.
Ja, kluge Worte zum Schluss, hoffen wir mal, dass euer Gesetzesentwurf es dann doch noch äh auch ins äh Verkündigungsplatz schafft.
Ja, wäre schön.
Gespannt äh ab und zu tut das auch mal ganz gut, wenn sich mal wieder was verbessert.
Absolut.
Wir hier permanent unsere unser Klagelied in die Hitparade schicken müssen.
Und so tut das mal gut, ja.
Okay, Volker, nochmal Dankeschön. Danke fürs Zuhören, danke fürs Unterstützen von Lobbuch, Netzpolitik, danke, fürs Weitersagen und ja, wir bleiben euch treu, nächste Woche geht's weiter. Bis bald.
Bis bald, ciao ciao.